you
didn't see that coming did you why did the toky come back to
apex all of a sudden what was that what was that cryptic
tweet she posted yesterday with the watson plus is she
trying to promote watson watson plushies or watson merch for
apex that's right i'm in the game for those who don't know
let me pin the tweet right now that's right people were like
oh my god kept all the surprise got spoiled the plus she got
leaked that wasn't the real surprise that was the red heron
oh my god plot twist this was the real surprise i'm in the
game guys all right for those who do not have twitter and
are really confused right now like what is dokey talking
about that she's in the game all right let me show you guys
a special video that was Just tweet it out.
Like, not, like, literally four minutes ago.
That was scheduled out.
All right, are you guys ready?
Apex Legends.
My name is Doki.
That's me!
I'm a YouTuber, primarily known for my FPS skills.
I'm RoboScarloot, and I created the skin for Watson with
Doki.
So, the Watson skin, it's basically me.
Like, they have my bandana there, my jacket.
And the best part is she's blonde.
I'm blonde.
I decided to pick some of the most obvious elements of
Loki's character presence on the skin, like the boots and
the straps, especially the specific belts that she has.
And also the one that I was really excited about was her
little tomato.
Oh yeah, by the way, we got the cut tomato.
I'm sorry.
That could kill this entire body.
He's like, the little tomato.
I'm so cute.
I'm sorry, guys.
It was a little, little rewarding.
The tomato got cut.
I really hope that people like the skin and the effort that
was put in.
It's just a really, really cool bounty hunter slash Western
aesthetic.
No, but we replaced it with someone things better and
terrorize the rank lobbies with Watson.
All right, okay, okay, okay.
No, the tomato got cut, but there was, there was a reason
for it.
All right.
Okay, look, look.
Okay, here, right here.
All right.
Oh my God, where is it?
Where's the skin?
The scrap, especially the specific belts that she has.
No, it was a long interview.
It was like a 30 minute, it was like a 20 to 30 minute.
Okay, so to replace, we had to make a really tough decision
because they, uh, they forgot to do my ocee mark which was
the trophy the trophy mark so then uh we had to make the
because it was supposed to be on the ears of the watson so
we were running out of time so i was like just replace the
trophy ocee mark with the tomato because i felt like it
would be much much better so then you guys can like like um
you guys can like brandish the ocee mark as well when you're
playing watson so people be like oh that's that's you know
um their ocee is dokey bird so the ocee mark i felt the
ocean mark was much more important so it's gonna be a it's a
trophy on the patches instead of tomato it was a very tough
decision because like if the tomato was really inside me for
the tomato it was like it was like pretty her character is a
big cowboy old western look and i decided to keep that look
i really hope look on that way let me look it's me
i'm back baby i'm back on apex I'm literally in the game
it's literally me all right so the reason why um so yes we
are back in the basement oh my god it was so hard to keep
this a secret guys it was it was really really hard to keep
it a secret because it's been in the works for half a year
now and um I I when I got the the apex devs from respawn
that they wanted to include me in the seventh anniversary um
i was just like did you get the right person like because
like obviously you know i haven't been playing apex that
much recently in recent like years so i was just like so
surprised that they so went up to me and was like we really
want you on this seven year anniversary and um and they gave
me a skin too which is crazy because it's like what there's
a lot of things it's like a tracker there's like trackers
there's gun skins um there's uh there's stats and stuff or
like banners but and the skin the character skins is like
the most coveted spot for the anniversary and um so each
creator they choose uh a select they select uh uh pool of
creators uh like around 10 creators I believe like I think
it was like I don't remember how many creators it selected
for this year but it's usually around like six to not like
six to ten creators every year um and usually the the
character skins are the rarest ones to get because they're
like the most coveted position during the anniversary and
the fact that they gave me um a character skin and i get to
pick the character i wanted uh for my anniversary skin so i
personally picked watson for my character skin for the 7th
anniversary and the reason because if you guys know the
dokey bird lore watson was the first character i played that
got me apex predator um and uh in the in my first like the
first time i've ever got apex predator i played watson and
it was more so like it went in full circle so it was
dedicated to the character that i felt like took me to get
top 500 apex and back when I first started playing and the
fact that they let me be Watson I really appreciate a huge
shout out to the devs to the team for the entire experience
going through like designing the characters and everything
it felt like I was going through like a full circle I spent
thousands of hours in this game a game that I dedicate
thousands of hours in and like that's me that's literally me
so the reason why I'm doing early access stream is that we
can actually see my skin in the early axis.
So let me boot it up real quick.
Let me boot up the game super quick.
But yes, that's why we're doing early axis because my skin
is actually in the game in early axis right now.
You guys can actually play as me.
I can like, you can go into lobbies and just wear my skin.
It's like insane to think about.
Yeah, I still can't believe it's so surreal.
that it's actually real.
I feel like I never ever thought that I would ever be picked
for the anniversary, especially like the newer like the
recent years as well.
So I like I'm just I'm just like speechless right now.
Like I have to keep this a secret for so long.
You can wear the Doki Bird skin suit.
Oh my god.
Also I did a little warm up.
I did like an hour warm up before then and I felt like so
clunky trying to play Apex again because it's been so long
since I've played like a movement shooter and oh my god like
there's so many new changes I didn't know but did you guys
know I was because I was practicing Watson but did you guys
know that the Watson fences don't destroy doors anymore I
was like oh my god like that's so strong yeah so like they
they changed so many things it's like it's like sort of a
whole new different game now yeah they don't for those who
have this is like the perfect time to come back to apex too
there's so many new changes and also the perfect time
because you can play as me uh i don't know when they change
that but there has been a lot of big changes there's been a
lot of changes in apex since i've last touched the game um
all right that's me like dokey bird all right oh my gosh i'm
so oh my god i'm oh the seventh anniversary all right
where's my where is it oh my god where is it i'm i don't oh
i need to figure out where they put my skin i'm i'm all over
the place right now i still can't believe it's it's real i
still can't believe it's real right now uh where am i where
am i
oh yeah okay that's where it's here it's here it's this it's
this that's me wait there it is there it is it's right here
it's right here why is it that's me right here oh my god
there's me look at it look see see it's a little trophy and
there's the uh see look there's the trophy it's a challenge
to unlock so there's the the Yoshi mark it's a 4,000 point
reward it's the challenges and then look the little stars
and everything so in the ass and so we try to add as many
elements whereas like it's Doki Bird but also like it's its
own thing too it looks so cool it's so shiny and everything
too like you can see here oh my god I wish I can zoom in but
do you see the little bird the bird right here the bird
emblem and then the bullet the bullet thing here too The
bullets on the shoes.
And then...
And then my bandana.
And then, like I said, there's the...
The Oshi mark.
So we swap the tomato.
Or the...
Yeah, this is an epic skin.
It's not even a legendary.
And then all the belts and everything.
And then the stars.
And oh my god.
It looks so good.
I can't but like...
You wear this and you're like, Hey, that looks like Donkey
Bird's outfit.
And it is!
Because it is Donkey Bird's outfit.
It's me!
that was she is and she is and i'm i'm fine i made it guys i
i finally made it oh my god i thought you were on highest
that was a that was a joke towards past retro dokey time era
when before before i like long time ago i usually did a lot
of high ends back then so it was like a time because it was
a time travel segment um there so i was just doing a little
throwback joke but like Yatus, guys.
Like, I'm still streaming.
Oh, my God, I'm a playable character.
We actually made it, guys.
We did it.
We made it.
Oh, I love the Oshi mark, too.
I love that, like, you know, you know, it's like a little
badge, like a little Boy Scout badge, you know?
They'd be like, yeah, that's my Oshi.
That's right.
I'm repting her.
Oh, sorry.
Okay.
Okay, sorry.
Um,
um but um it's it's it's so crazy it's it's so crazy to to
like see this like actually you know being in the game and
everything and like it felt like a full circle moment and um
like I didn't even thought this was going to happen, you
know, because it's not like, oh, like, it's already, um, I
felt like, you know, at this point in my career, like, um,
it was never really going to happen because I've, like,
obviously, I've, um, I haven't played Apex as much as I used
to in the past.
So it was, I was so shocked and surprised when the devs, um,
reached out to me and be like, do you want to be in our
seven year anniversary?
Like, do you want to have a cosmetic for the, seven-year
anniversary and it was so crazy it's i i did i was like are
you sure you sent it to the right person like but but like
it's like i really want to say thank you to the devs for
reaching out and like choosing me for this anniversary the
fact that they like acknowledged me as like someone
important in their community and history of the game to be
given the skin and it's like a played, by the way, seven
years ago, I started playing this game seven years ago, and
with my friends that like, ended up starting my VTuber
career, and was the reason why I was picked to join the
company in the first place, and like, this game literally
opened so many doors for me, um, and like, was the reason
why I started taking FPS games much more seriously in the
past, because, you know, in Overwatch, I just played Lucy.
and support but like here like here in apex i actually
focused on like playing like you know training my aim and
getting better at like you know getting better at like being
an aimer and like improving myself like like when for like
years and years trying to be better at like shooting my gun
and everything like tracking um tracking flicking and
everything and i have apex to thank for that um and it was
the game that sort of put my name uh in the vtubing
community so i really appreciate the devs for picking me and
for uh letting me be part of something really special um in
um in the game and it's it's crazy that i got a skin like a
cosmetic skin
to to think about like that this is actually real like i
thought this would never happen especially because like um
you know i have been playing a lot of i've been going more
variety to in my more recent career so um and it i guess it
revitalized my passion and love for apex that like no matter
what like i always come back to apex in the end and i always
like it was caused for me the basement is always calling for
me no matter what i feel like i sort i think i was the one
that started the apex basement joke being like come back to
the basement guys like
yeah and like i think i was one that sort of like started
the whole joke about like the basement and everything and
the people started using it was like oh no the basement the
apex basement you never truly leave the apex basement it
always calls you back um and it was a game that i got a lot
of people into as well uh and i know like a lot of dragoons
have talked to me and told me being like apex was the one to
introduce me like you were the one that introduced me to
apex like i love watching you taught me a lot about this
game when i first started streaming and everything so it is
a huge honor um uh and uh it is a huge honor to be
know a part of its history uh and yeah i hope to see a lot
of dragons wearing this watson skin to show that you know uh
to show their support because it's just it is a challenge so
um it is like easier to obtain because it's just like
challenges and stuff so you don't need to pay for uh you
don't really have to pay for it you can just um you can just
uh uh uh just like like complete challenges to get the skin
yourself um so here like some of the challenges that you can
do and then you complete all these challenges you complete
all these challenges you will eventually get this yay and
apex comes out tomorrow uh the new season i believe comes
out tomorrow yes it's technically free because all you have
to do is just complete challenges and the more challenges
you get uh the more challenges you complete uh the obviously
like the more points you gain and then it'll end up getting
you the the uh this you know getting all these rewards and
stuff so this there's this and everything there's i think
this was greeks this one's greeks skin but all these are
like content creator stuff right here so there's other the
other content creators and everything and you know mine's at
the middle you know mine's at the middle So, it's not as
hard of a grind as 6,000.
It's right here.
In the middle.
Right here.
Oh, Mirage, Kings of Foil.
Wait, I wonder if...
Uh...
That's a sick, too.
That's a sick-ass skin as well.
Yeah, yeah, middle.
See, right here.
Right after the Mirage skin, you can get mine.
And it's right...
right here um and but yeah i hope you guys uh install it for
those who have left apex and are looking to come back
tomorrow is the perfect time to do it because my skin is in
it you know and so yeah it's a perfect time to come back you
haven't come back in a long time and you want to see all the
new changes which is why i'm going to be showcasing in the
the fire range today tomorrow sorry not today today is where
you watch me play apex um where i showcase the early season
but tomorrow is where you get you get to try out the game
again or if you are you've been you haven't left you know
new season new changes uh new stuff um yeah guess and i hope
you guys all run into a lot of dragons who are playing
watson um or fight for watson fair you have to get never
mind never mind i've realized you have to do the challenges
and stuff but but you know what i mean when you get the skin
after the challenge after you complete the challenges then
you can fight all the other dragoons to play watson and you
get to show you get to and you get to kill other dragoons
too you see another dragoon in the ring and you're like you
there can only be one watson uh you know you can challenge
other dragoons in the wild and be like oh my god i know what
you are um anyway let us go to fire range because i believe
we can only access fire range for now but don't worry it'll
be in like 30 minutes we'll be fine um all right here we go
let's go in where i should play just gotta wait for the fire
range to boot up and everything should be good oh my gosh
it's it's crazy oh yeah before i forget to mention there was
another thing but i saw that did get leaked already but that
was why for those who are wondering why i posted a watson
picture a watson plus plushy picture and why was just the
back it's because wait where is it it's because surprise
it's actually me as well So tomorrow, tomorrow, the Watson
dokeybird plushie is dropping tomorrow on YouTube's.
And it will be up for pre-order for four weeks.
So you to celebrate the launch, the launch of me as Watson,
we actually have a physical plushie of me as Watson that
will be up tomorrow on YouTube's that you can pre-order.
the free order will be up for four weeks by the way so yes
that's all the surprises oh my god it's here but wait
there's more so yes you can actually you can grab this
special crossover huge shout out to EA for letting me be
Watson for I guess a month make me a physical uh be able to
do a collaboration with EA on something on a physical
product as well so uh i really appreciate it um and it's
it's honestly like it's it's really crazy i told you this
week was gonna be crazy there's more for this week too but
today we got another today is apex day it's also funny like
i just had my anniversary and apex is having their
anniversary too and then you know it just all worked out
together you know everything just coordinated together like
it's both our anniversaries and we're both celebrating
something very special um very special like this week too um
but yeah oh my god that's all the surprises it was this and
also me right here oh where am i where is my where is my
when do i get to go get into
matchmaking i just want to go to the fog oh wait that's the
training oops sorry i'm i'm i'm oh my gosh i'm fumbling i'm
just i'm just so oh my gosh i'm all over the place right now
i'm so i just can't believe that you know that i'm here
don't keep believes it it's just crazy you know that i'm
like here i'm that's me right here in the game i feed i'm
spilling my spaghetti right now it's been so long okay but
like i think it's crazy that this is a new thing i might
need some veteran goons uh veteran goons and apex to tell
let me know what they change okay this is the crazy part
look it doesn't destroy doors anymore so like that's so
that's so op because you can i don't know when this change
went into effect but like the fact that like i can't shoot
the fences is so strong so like yeah that that shit is so
strong yeah it's crazy i was like oh my because i was
practicing watson i was like oh my god oh and the doors too
yeah apparently the doors hurt too because um because it's
energized now i didn't even know when that change went into
effect i was that's new to me it's new to me it is all right
what are the new stuff guys do you guys happen to know what
else is new for me to what are the shiny new things i can
play around with yeah but for those who are who are coming
back they might not notice that yeah fuse what have they
done the fuse huge changes all right what is it this is the
same this is the same oh my god is this the same oh okay
that never mind that did not that is not the same that is
just like wait a minute that yeah that is new that is
definitely not the same guy i was like oh he's bringing out
his little cannon surely he's just gonna shoot some fire and
i was like oh that is not just fire oh that is that is new
new all right what else oh wait i don't have my skins god
damn it not my i don't have my pay to win skins oh no i
gotta get used i gotta use my wait i gotta use the actual
scopes All right, what are the perks?
Gina, I should be able to upgrade my perks.
Where is it?
There it is.
All right.
All right, what are new perks?
Upgrades, persistent frames, jumps near your attack for a
boost and 50% recharge?
Oh my gosh, which would be better?
I guess the rocket jump, right?
Got me an upgrade.
Oh, my God.
Wait, we can rocket jump now.
Wait, that's crazy.
We can fucking rocket jump now.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Okay, so I have to be on it.
Okay, wait.
That's actually insane.
I know Octane is, like, super strong.
I was, like, playing pubs earlier to practice, because it's
been a while, so I have to remember how to do the movement
stuff.
Yeah, okay.
I was just like, do I still know how to tap strafe?
Okay, technically.
Yeah, yeah, I still know.
Okay, that was me not tap strafe.
I'm gonna say, I wanted to see if that was tap.
Yeah, I do know how to tap strafe.
Okay.
I still know how to tap strafe.
I still got it, guys.
I still got it.
But the rocket jump is fun.
Yeah, you know, I know you can super glide super easy
because it's literally an instruction on my screen, which
thankfully, I can sort.
See, look at that.
Super Look at that!
Yeah!
That's so OP.
There you go.
And...
Alright, what else does do?
Octay?
What did they do to Octay?
I mean, that's still the same.
Wait, what?
Hold?
What?
What is this?
What is different between this and Q?
Wait, I gotta read this.
What is different?
Q tactical increased walk speed by cost used twice to sim
search gain 42 and activating swift men what the and who
will heal and you get fortified wait i can b hop now it's
got time oh my god wait oh no wonder oh my okay no wonder
everyone was playing octane in my pubs oh my but i'm so bad
too fast though that's okay i'm the thing is that's so
strong but i'm also really when things get too fast i can't
aim anymore like i my brain shuts down when things get too
fast okay wait yeah
okay okay okay but if i you know i was i'm casually running
here like like it's a lot easier Okay, I had a feeling that
was gonna happen.
I feel like It's too fast.
It's too fast.
I'm so bad when it's too fast.
All right, what are my upgrades?
All right.
Minus 10, Sim Actor Landing from a Jump Pad.
That sounds okay.
I know what else.
Sim Search is longer with less as fast reloads with shield
crack.
all right do i stim oh my god i do i can go so fast oh my
god okay all right and then the other one was just taking
less hp oh my god literally like regent all the hp that i
used wait everyone gets it too that is so strong okay now i
think i gotta i gotta practice octane
oh my god wait that's actually insane yeah the speed is
crazy okay but then like when you're too fast you can't
really aim guys you gotta remember that like i think like
you're too fast unless you have a controller it gets really
hard to aim guys it gets really hard to track when you go
too fast you know it's a little it's the exchange yeah who
needs aim when you can fly The cost of being too fast.
like, I can see someone doing that shit.
Being like...
I need to find some ammo.
Okay.
We need to aim with the skill issue, Doki.
Just a little skill issue.
What else, guys?
What else is new?
We still have, like, 30 minutes to look through all the new
stuff.
I get so overwhelmed if I go too fast.
I didn't...
I get weak.
No wonder.
No wonder I see everyone playing.
this character.
Can do sideway ults now.
Has she always been able to do sideway ults?
You can rotate it, I'm pretty sure.
Oh yeah, Valk.
We can turn down the game sound a bit.
Alright, sure.
Alright, I'll turn down the game sound a little bit.
Alright, I know, no, Valk is crazy.
Okay, so, because, like, one of my friends, because I was
playing with my friends, and one of my friends, um, let's
see.
Where's Valk?
oh my gosh just how little I play Valc I do not play her
because I can't bunny hop with her I don't like playing Valc
because because I love bunny hopping and I can't bunny hop
when I have Valc on because she just does her little fly so
that's why I never play Valc but it's crazy because I didn't
know if this like okay minus 5 second and was a real okay so
this because like you know it's been a while since I came
back so um so the crazy part was that i didn't realize they
reworked some of her perks as well uh and like this perk is
crazy i don't know when this perk was reworked but it was
not there when i was playing it and and then like this all
launchers players much faster now and it was insane because
when you up it's so fast okay oops it's crazy because i can
attract people like it where people are in buildings now.
So like, if there's like people in the building, the alt can
look, can find them in buildings.
So I was like not, I was like very surprised about that.
Yeah.
So when you're in the sky, but it's a perk, by the way.
It's this perk.
I'm just revealing and through walls.
Through walls.
This perk is old.
Not, okay, it's old for some people, but some people might
have not been able to, recently so like for me that was new
it was a new perk for me because I I didn't remember this I
know that but like for those who haven't who you know took a
break from apex and are coming back tomorrow you're like
some of the things that you might not have been able might
not know about lately that has got changed over the last
couple of months Maggie runs faster with yeah Valk clearly
has was.
It's insane.
What was it?
What else?
What are changes for this season, guys?
But those are the changes I noticed that I've never seen
before, uh, until, until like, yes, today.
Cal is tactical is better, bigger now.
Okay, where's Cat is this?
I'm low on ammo.
Should find some more.
Yeah, I can flip it.
Oh, the flip is easy.
I like the flip.
Is it taller?
I feel like it was never this tall before, right?
Wait, this feels taller.
I feel like it's a lot.
You can break windows.
Where is a window?
Oh, what?
There's windows in this game?
Wait.
When did they add windows?
Oh my god, they added wind Did I get shorter or like They
get bigger Oh my god, when did the Buildings have windows?
We finally Can see outside
Oh my god That's new The glass update We finally guys,
finally The sun can The sun can shine in They just did.
Oh my god, it's crazy.
We're gonna try to find buildings.
You can be like breach
We can reinforce them.
Oh my god, I'm breaching.
I'm breaching and be like All right, we can finally afford
windows guys.
Oh my gosh, finally We can see it outside FBI open up they
change it someone said bloodhound all right blood what did
they change on bloodhound
uh i actually don't know what juan i won't play i won't play
watson but then i need to i grab my skin though we'll do
first game on watson just to celebrate celebrate my new my
new skin i think your ui needs to be adjusted is it oh my
gosh it does it's been so long The UI doesn't fit no more.
Oh my god, it doesn't fit no more.
Oh my god, they changed it so much that it don't fit no
more, guys.
Oh no.
Alright.
Alright, what?
What do they change for Bloodhound, chat?
Yeah, I need a new one now.
what did they change chat i don't mind not it's it's like
i'm i'm i'm really happy today today is a good day oh plus
perks all right oh hey my bird's here now oh is he like
taking me to where the enemies are is that what he's doing
my little bird oh that's awkward
the miles range infinite there you go that's awkward was
this so does expand no it has to be a perk yeah bird that
part's not wait what did they change then all right let's
check when wave is fine white wave is fine enemies at twice
the range plus 50 HP unknocked while alt is active I don't
even know which one would scoopy good uh i would say this
and then attack activates faster minus five quote percent
double duration attack double duration attacks full body i
feel like faster would be stronger you can have up forever
like before yeah that alt lasted though i will say the alt
looks like it lasted for a while.
Yeah.
That all seemed like I had it for a while, too.
They buffed wall climbing during ult?
Wee.
Alright, let's let's get my ult real fast.
It feels a lot faster, for sure.
Let's see.
Oh, I don't have any mag here.
1 or 2 seconds.
Wait, where are the people?
Hit.
14.
I don't think it increases.
Did I got the wrong person?
Yeah, no, it's the same.
But the alt is...
The alt is very...
Very long.
The ult seems to...
Oh, it doesn't work in fire range.
But the ult does seem very long when I boot it up.
Knocks don't happen.
Oh, I have to wait till the knock.
I see.
That's...
Yeah.
But it looks like the ult is longer than what I'm used to.
But you can make it even longer.
I don't know.
It feels a lot longer.
I swear.
Bloodhound did not have an alteration that long before when
I used to play.
Uh, what else?
What else?
Is there anything else new, chat?
You also regen with Noxia.
I saw that.
I got the leech.
All right, go, my bird.
Bang smoke on doors.
What does that mean?
Check that out.
Let me add him.
All right, let me add him.
okay that that was instant oh my god she finally upgraded
her smokes she got the tax money finally the government
upgraded oh my holy it's like a fucking missile
it only took seven years it really Oh my god, it's like I'm
shooting a missile into the goddamn house.
Can I, can I like knock down the window?
Let's see.
Dynamic.
Oh, is there?
Oh, there's, you know, I was going to say, I want to get rid
of cooldowns.
We got to wait 13 seconds.
It does, yeah, it's always, the damage seems a lot.
Wait, actually, I saw 100 on the damage.
From smoke, yeah, from smoke grenade to smoke rocket, bro.
This is actual rocket now.
does it pierce windows time to find out no the windows are
fine where the doors made of i don't know if the in my
fucking smoke rocket got upgraded or the door or they ran
out of funding on the doors so now they're made out of
styrofoam uh windows are stronger than a glass window is
stronger than a reinforced door all right how much damage oh
no what the fuck did i hit okay the smoke doesn't do damage
apparently on people but it does damage oh maybe i hit the
other door oh i hit the other door wait watson can reinforce
windows let me check i'm gonna add so many new shiny things
i feel we charged oh my god she can it's purple now how many
windows i'm reinforcing i'm do wait there's a cooldown okay
but how strong is this window oh that's a strong-ass window
not gonna lie that's a lot of bullets that's okay now it's
blue okay okay oh now it's white oh it's like purple blue
and white armor oh i get it so there's this oh So the
windows are purple armor.
Oh, yeah.
Apparently all controller.
Not like controller as in the input.
But all.
All control.
So classic.
Watson.
Rampart.
Yeah, this.
Apparently the walls are different too.
Alright.
I'm building walls.
What's different?
Oh, what?
though oh my god i have a roof now oh my god i can actually
build a home i get wait wait wait i can actually build a
house wait a minute
yay my little house oh my god well i got her way i couldn't
use this again it's like bangalore or or give me a i'm no
longer homeless i have my own little home uh let me try it
uh it's giving I don't think I've tried on Showdown, but,
um, and it's also because it's an extraction shooter, so
name is Super Chat Sorcerer.
Thank you.
Oh my god, I'm no longer homeless.
I have my own home.
Oh, she has unlimited ammo as a perk.
I know they reworked a lot of perks, too.
Bigger ammo stacks, extra.
Oops, that's not what I wanted.
Bastarillo and Infinite ammo.
Wow, behind Amp Shield.
Excuse me?
Wait, is that not the Amp Shield?
Wait, did I not get that?
Okay, Amp Cover will regenerate.
Improve Shield of Hand.
Okay, wait.
Faster reloads and Infinite went behind.
Amp Cover and Amp Shield is intact.
How do I get the Infinite Ammo?
Unless this is the Infinite Ammo they're talking about.
I need to...
Oh, I need to put new walls up.
Okay, don't worry.
Alright.
out of here okay i'm building my new home all right this is
my do i need ammo first i'm low on ammo okay i need one
stack okay i will test this out yeah i'm just remodeling
real quick
i'll put one stack and see if it works oh my god there you
go i have to have one stack already okay that's pretty cool
that's a pretty neat change yeah alright anything else guys
anything else that they changed oh it's almost time it's
almost time to game it's almost time to queue up with all
the other creators can you build my oh yeah the reload is
insane too yeah you need to have well no I had like I'm
pretty sure like had like, uh, one, like, one mag, um, in
my, uh, vault, and it didn't let me, it didn't let me have
infinite reload.
Look, okay, see?
I don't know, maybe, or maybe it just took a, I had to grab
new ammo.
Horizon has a drone she can fly.
Oh, wait, never mind.
I just had, I guess I had to grab new ammo.
It doesn't work with old ammo.
Oh yeah, it doesn't, it doesn't work with old ammo.
okay horizon can glide now all right what's this we're back
you missed this another we picked me up i guess it's a perk
right another soft landing all right an air to fast fall
after a press oh that's new what else soft landing ground
shield region gain extra ability charge on knock i feel like
oh my god i don't even know which one would be good.
If you're super aggressive, knock expert would be great.
If you're super aggressive.
Right?
They're both so strong.
Yeah, the knock is bad.
Yeah, I was going to say, I feel like the knock would be
better if you're a super aggressive player because then you
didn't have your Q again.
Super, you didn't have your Q.
But then if we were like, worry about like sustained, then I
guess like...
Other for the shield regen.
I feel like this would be better if you're just like an
aggressive player But I want to know how's that We
This is a redeploy this is like what the fuck I'm literally
redeploying I
Oh my god, I can literally oh my god went all the way here.
I was over Wait a minute, wait a minute, I'm actually, I'm
actually flying.
Uh, they nerfed that by the way.
I was mad at their, oh my god, the fact that this is a, wee.
I'm all the way here.
Oh my god, I'm across the map.
How strong, how, how strong was this before?
where did this go to where that's the nerd version how far
did i go to like i i use this in king's canyon and then i'm
in olympus is that how it was before i was like we in king's
canyon and suddenly i'm in olympus like
now we horizon rotating now and yes
you can release and read up wait that's so true wait a
minute let's try this if you tap it gives you what if I tap
it occasionally so I'll be like we oh my god you're right
and wait you're right wait you're right okay if I do it
correctly I can actually go further that's crazy I have to
just have it This is some new-ass tech that I'm learning,
right?
Okay, now I don't even know what to play.
All these characters are so fun, yeah.
Yeah, because, like, she gets, like, a little bit of hype.
I just don't know the tech, I just don't know the timing for
the tap.
I need to figure out the timing to tap it.
I think if I tap it correctly, I could go crazy with this.
I could literally rotate into a different map.
I could be on the other side, and then the ring is closing,
and I could go to the other side of the ring.
Alright, what else?
Is there anything else?
Yeah, I know about their passive.
They changed their passive?
I actually don't know.
Increases arrow, control, and reduces fall impact.
Anyone's passive got changed?
Octane.
Oh, I know.
I saw it, but I tried to octane caustic.
causing damage with gas opening death box opening death
boxes really okay uh i didn't realize opening death boxes
though now too six canister reinforced hard light zone
overcharge how is caustic op that was enlightening it
doesn't seem that what did he change other than this opening
death boxes yeah you can have all perks on him oh my god
what are his perks i forgot about the perks all tactical
charge re okay that one i remember i remember when i did the
hide-and-seek tournament regen hp inside yeah i remember
that and then one plus this one was strong i remember he
takes damage faster now we're charged 300 faster inside the
gas plus 50 okay i feel like that's crazier how far is this
My vision is clear.
Okay, I'm still in it.
Oh, my God.
Okay, I can literally control an entire zone.
How about this?
300%.
Nades on...
Okay, did they change?
I remember last time played, I didn't realize Nade gets rid
of gases.
Is that still the same?
Or did they change that?
I remember because I was like, Oh, my God, it's so long.
Okay, my...
gas thing goes away but like but like does it destroy my gas
ult though
still the same what about my ult does it destroy my ult or
yeah all right i remember that i didn't realize that was a
change because i could have got more kills during the hot
and sea i i could have got more kills during hot and sea if
i didn't through my ult and then 20 names
All right, let's see.
Oh, yeah, it does.
Yeah, the gas is gone.
Imagine.
Oh, it temporarily disperses.
Oh, okay.
It's still back there.
It's just the cans are gone.
Never mind.
It temporary disperses only.
I still...
Yeah, but I could have killed the entire lobby.
Guys.
It could have been an entire lobby.
Yeah, it's any Nade, but for your ult, you have to But then
you have to nade yourself, though.
That's the thing.
If you're ulted And then you try to throw a nade to disperse
the gas, you're nading yourself.
So, like, it's like a sacrifice.
You want to take damage From your own nade?
Or, like,
Yeah.
all can go through walls now?
No way.
Is it really?
Alright, where's where's a building?
Oh yeah.
Wait, you're right.
I got hit here.
Yo, can charge the bow.
Can take similar scopes.
Oh my god, they brought that back.
That shit was so broken.
That's how I got Apex Brady.
I'll abuse the fuck out of G7 and charge rifle.
Right click for breach mode.
Oh, use right click?
I'm nearly empty.
Okay.
Let me try.
I'll grab more.
Oh yeah, I need to do this again.
Alt creates jump near tactic.
I saw the unlimited ammo on Krayber.
I saw that unlimited ammo works.
on red guns, which is scary.
I also had that.
I also actually had the perk, wow, with the creeper, like,
when I was practicing an hour before stream.
Breach mode.
What the fuck?
I'm breaching?
Oh, shit.
Wait, that's... Oh, my god.
That's crazy.
Alternator can double tap?
What does that even mean?
There's so many new chains
What do you mean?
Alternator can double tap.
What does that mean?
There's no alternator.
Yeah, I can clean the whole floor now.
What do you mean by double tap?
Fire's two quick shots per trigger pull.
Cannot be removed?
Is it?
Oh, meet the upgrade.
Oh!
Two shots per trigger pulled.
I don't see that working.
Oh, press B.
Oh, there it is.
I see it now.
Oh, okay.
I see it.
I didn't...
Oh, my God.
That seems like a, yeah, it's...
I'm trying to like...
Oh my god.
Okay, that's...
Seems strong.
It is, yeah, two bullets, slower, but two bullets, so two is
better than one.
Two might be better than one.
That's no range.
Let's see.
if you can control your recoil but then you can't really get
headshots g7 wait what time is it oh two more minutes all
right let's check the g7 g7 wait it's in sniper where's my
g7 at wait where did it oh they put it as oh my god it's
been so young oh okay i put as a red gun oh It's a care
package gun.
Okay, that's interesting.
All right, let's put a...
Apparently you can put a sniper scope now.
So...
Oh, where is it?
2x4.
I mean, 2x4 is really pretty crazy.
Where the fuck is the sniper stuff?
Oh, fuck it.
This is why they removed sniper scope.
I don't know if you guys remember.
But they...
They removed...
Dirk.
Um...
This is how I got Apex Predator.
She's in...
Is how...
That in Charge Rifle is how I got Apex Predator.
I literally just...
Put a sniper scout on my G7.
And then just farm the shit of people for...
For RP.
Like that shit is so broken.
At least it's a care package weapon though.
You know?
At least we have that.
Yeah.
They brought it back.
But it's a care package, so it's harder to...
Usually I do this.
I was so good at, like, back then, when I played this game
every day, I was so good at, like, hip-firing, too.
I would do this.
I would hip-fire G7 for close range, because it was so
strong.
Like, I would do this.
If I get pushed.
Like, a G7.
Yeah.
It was really good.
It was...
And now they can have unlimited ammo.
Oh my gosh, it's time.
It's time, guys.
It's time!
We gotta queue up!
Leave it as is.
I guess it's...
I think wildcard is later, but for now you can play...
You can play unranked.
Oh my gosh, it's time, the game!
Oh!
I don't know what to play.
every all the characters I want your first one would be I
think first one definitely for sure Watson to celebrate I
know I don't have wait do I have I have 600 crafting no no
oh wait oh oh wait wait how long okay we're still
matchmaking okay I think I think I missed the queue I think
everyone queued up exactly three all right oh wait wait okay
is it unlocked it might be though right it's an epic skin um
oh my god it is inspired by donkey bird designed by yeah
it is in here oh my god it actually is in here oh that's so
cool that's so fucking cool it actually is in here It's me!
Alright, I need to put...
Let me...
I need to put my Padawine skin on here.
Where is it?
There you go.
It's not my usual one, but...
I don't remember what it's called.
It was the Ice one, I'm pretty sure.
The Ice one was my favorite.
Here you go.
That's my usual.
And then, I guess I should do the Wingman, too, just in
case.
Where is it?
It is Sniper.
Wait.
Is it not?
what the fuck oh there he is i was gonna say but it's not
sniper ammo why is it non okay where's my uh that's not my
usual but i don't know what all right there uh where's my
usual it'll win i think it was this yeah was it no that one
was too thick i don't remember which one it is guys which
one was it which one was the oh wait oh the skin is sick
sure it's not too thick oh here here the sunburst this one
there it is i remember now is this i'm pretty sure that's
not the thick one right or is it death ray yeah there's
death ray where the where the is death ray there you go
there you go my usual wingman skin
141 that's a lot of players that's a
oh that should seriously be yeah but that's why it's pay to
win there's less thick there's also the flat line too but i
don't remember which what which one is but because i don't
use the flat line
oh that's crazy it's actually crazy that i'm here
believe it look like I'm literally looking at myself oh my
god all those years crying about crying about apex legends
getting stream sniped during ring grinds getting apex
predator all those years it led me to this moment I never
thought I was gonna get an anniversary skin I thought like
you know it was already past my peak my prime when I used to
like my my peak apex era I was like oh they will never
choose me and the fact that they did let me be part of apex
history being part of the apex history and and celebration
uh I made it I actually made it that's why last year when
you guys were like oh what goals do you want to do for your
uh new year's resolution and i was like it's so hard to
write what i want i want for 2026 because a lot of things
are happening in 2026 and like i can't spoil it but you know
like one of them you guys were like oh getting in being in
and in the game and i was like oh i can't say anything about
it i can't say anything about
I was just like I can't say anything about it I'm like Guys
I don't know I can't really I don't know what to write For
my new year's resolution
And it's an epic skin The fact that it's an epic skin And
there's so much like detail In it too Like the ocean mark
Like the the belt you see the the fucking belt itself too
this is just crazy but oh my god like every little detail is
there we're back we're actually back back to where it began
oh yeah put myself next year i can give me a sec oh that's
left side dokey we'll use this dokey all right here and then
um wait i can't move right now give me a sec all right
it'll be like this so
hello hey dokey another dokey in the dokeyverse
oh my god which one's the real dokey
which one which one
wait wait it should be oh my god right here wait i think
this is a close this is a better that oh my god you gotta
shoot take the shot take the shot i'm the real dokey bird
prove you're the real if you're the real dokey uh prove it
guys i'm the real dokey bird guys my right eye is red look
at the other dokey she doesn't have the red the red aimbot
eye that could be a contact lens dokey i think that's the
left one she's she's more blind than the other the red eye
equals evil dokey think again imposter hey i can't tell them
apart which who do i shoot
who is it real doki doesn't tuck in her straight that's
right that's why that's why i'm the real doki guys the real
doki wouldn't need an aim bot you almost fooled me it's so
cool oh my gosh i'm just so happy that he let me like do so
much customization on the skin itself i'm seeing okay i
gotta double check they said three right oh my gosh did i
get the time wrong yeah core battle royale at three okay i
didn't get it wrong we're all just waiting
the real jokie can do a black okay wait i can do a backflip
See, I told you guys I'm the real dokey.
I did a backflip.
Whose neck is longer?
Obviously mine.
See?
Well, I think we're at the same length, actually.
I think...
Sick.
That's a cartwheel.
Yeah, see, the fake dokey can't do that.
All she's doing is just looking left and right.
Oh, boss, but you know the real dokey.
Doki doesn't know her cardinal direction.
She can't tell from her front and back, guys.
Checkmate.
You know that.
You know the real Doki doesn't follow instructions.
It's a 50-50.
I follow it partially.
That's right.
I actually I'm gonna grab some... I didn't blow my nose.
My random tissues.
Give me a sec.
Just in time.
Because I... I was grabbing my tissues too all right okay
let me just get your mom's commission to read it yeah oh how
dope wait who's this guy his name is horse adjacent demon
how the am i supposed to know who that guy horse adjacent
demon what a name
All right You don't know horse adjacent demon he's a legend
around these parts All right, here we go.
I'm gonna get so shit on Amongst these creators who've never
left I'm sorry folks I wasn't cheating on you.
I swear I just we needed a break.
Okay, and now look at that my love has came back renewed
Dude!
It's getting back stronger than ever!
I don't even know there's stuff here.
Oh, what?
Oh, he's fighting already.
I'm gonna say, that's fast.
Where the fuck is he?
We're just...
We were on a break!
Oh, he's fine.
It was just one guy.
Wait, am I lagging?
I can fix this, don't worry.
Am I?
Can't tell.
It's not you, it's me.
I'm fine.
I want an R9 though.
I need an R9.
Just a little bit?
I don't have to fix it, but before I do, I need to see a
hundred and oh, I'll grab the carbine.
I heard carbine is good now.
You see it?
Alright, I can fix that.
I'll fix it.
Who's doing streamer mode in that early access?
Like
streamer mode in early access.
It's crazy.
Oh, what the fuck?
I thought I got a 3x.
Oh, no, that's not a 3x.
Still need an R9.
I'll go over to horse-adjacent demon, whoever he is.
Whatever this guy is.
I just feel like this is better.
I should select an upgrade.
I believe this upgrade will...
Wee!
Amanda!
How could you not know where's the chase a demon?
He's known around these parts.
Oh my god, see there's the windows.
Oh my god, nice.
Okay, I gotta find a lot of light ammo, though.
That's the risk I'm willing.
That's not gonna bite me in the ass.
Obviously, everything will be fine.
I would definitely find enough light ammo.
I'm not gonna run out, I believe.
I'm not gonna run out, right?
Oh my god.
Okay, there you go.
Another stat.
Is he fighting someone?
Grab that.
Oh, shit.
There is enemies.
Don't worry.
I'm gonna head over.
I'm flanking.
Don't worry.
I'll help.
And I'm gonna get, like, the fucking double, like,
two-timed.
Gone already?
You're right.
I just, as long as I have infinite ammo, it'll be fine.
That's right.
I don't know why I planted it there.
Don't worry, it's going to help us, guys.
Watch this.
This is going to help us in the long run.
Oh, he's using it to rocket jump.
Oh, that's smart.
The movement tech.
Wait, what?
There's people here.
Okay.
I hear them.
Oh shit!
I got scan.
Medkit time?
It's okay, we're saved?
No, bro pushed actually way too far.
For real.
That's right!
Double fence!
Oh shit.
Are you serious?
Okay, we gotta Oh my god, didn't reload Fuck Oh, no, I'm
dead No, I didn't reload I could have killed the other guy
Okay, you know what?
I did more than my Oh, it's controller Look, in the end I
did the most damage I'm not washed Not washed Because I did
the most damage.
That's all I'm going to say.
And I joined the fight.
Real.
Not washed.
These guys, they might play like every day.
But I got the most damage.
That's all that matters.
Not washed, guys.
Not washed.
Exactly.
That's all that matters.
matters.
That's all that matters, guys.
How the fuck?
Okay.
Where's the fuck is the... Okay, there's the spec date.
Oh, yeah, I know.
That's a... They got... They actually got a good lot.
They got... They actually got, like, a good... A good stack.
I'm still... Guys, I hit my shots.
You saw that.
I almost... You said if I had reloaded my second gun,
wouldn't it would have been fucking dead.
And I didn't die first.
My first, the teammate that died first was being stupid.
You saw him.
He fucking ran in the open.
Like, what are you doing, bro?
That's in your regular pub.
There's no casual players in here.
These are all content creators.
What are you doing?
And I knew I had to play it.
I had to be smart about it.
Oh, Doki would so...
No, I'm not talking about horse-adjacent demon.
I'm talking about the third guy.
Where the fuck he was?
His...
He was so unimportant to me.
He didn't matter to me that I don't even know what his name
was.
I didn't even know who he was.
I just knew about horse-adjacent demon.
You're right.
Retro-Doki would have every one.
Oh, my God.
That's a while, though.
How long?
I'm going to check how long.
servers are going up for okay it's two hours at least that's
good the fuse thing is so looks so fun i think the fuse or
horizon looks really fun i want to try fuse or horizon for
the next one
have to be smart didn't reload okay look it was like in the
okay i was getting jumped okay i was fucking getting jumped
the rising any changes i don't know if the changes are
recent but to me they're are new, you know?
It's new to me type deal.
That's some... Guys, these guys have been playing for seven
years.
I hope they can beam.
You know?
Okay, I don't know what the fuck this guy.
That guy is stupid for, like, uh, fight, like, fighting like
that, but, like, I hope they can beam.
Literally, they've been playing for, like, seven years,
like, non-stop.
These players?
If you can't...
Let me guess.
You're an Aries.
I think some people are three-stacking because you can horse
and chase and turkey.
Nitro, thank you for the super chat.
They, I'm pretty sure, like, some of these players are...
You can stack in early access as long as, like, the players
have each other in their friends list.
So you can technically stack in early access.
So I won't be surprised.
As long as, like, you have their...
Like, you know, obviously you have...
Yeah, but why don't you just solo?
Because this is a big moment, you know?
This is, like, a big moment for us.
I felt like this is a good time to, like, solo and just
celebrate a moment of me fucking actually being in the game.
I want to, like, celebrate it with all of you guys.
You guys didn't expect it, did you?
I wouldn't have expected out of it.
No, not Broken Moon.
No!
I'm not a huge fan of Broken Moon.
Don't worry.
I didn't expect it out of it.
I thought I was going to get, like, a tracker or, like, a
Gunskin.
I would have...
I think it would have been cool to get Gunskin as well.
Because then, like, everyone...
No one has to fight for the Watson, you know?
I want to try...
uh i'll try horizon actually i'll try horizon but like uh
but like like i said i wanted to like i thought watson was
such a special character to me because like i said i
couldn't have got apex predator without watch like without
playing watson at that time like i literally played watson
for my for my rank stacks for it and she's such a special
character to me because she was the character I got my first
top 500 on.
So I'm really happy that I'm really happy for that
opportunity.
And the fact that, you know, you can have the Oshi mark is
there too.
So you know, like, you know, who your Oshi is.
And that the skin also works as a non-Youtuber skin too.
My second option would have been an R9 skin.
An R9 gun skin.
because it is my, you know, R9 was my go-to gun when I
grinded rank.
It was my, it's my best gun.
It's always been my best weapon.
Ah, fuck.
Holy fuck, no gun, really?
Oh my god.
I'm not worried to hell.
Where is he?
There we go.
Okay.
Okay, you know, I'm like, are these real players?
I'm trying to remember that these are all real players.
Oh my god, they broke my window.
Yeah, that's a thing.
It actually broke my window.
where is he what oh
my god you're fucking wait i fucking stunned myself oh my
god i can't do anything about it this is bad i need another
weapon are you serious
Oh my god.
I can't glide yet.
No!
I couldn't.
I didn't have chest.
Okay, look.
I felt like I was 1v3ing.
Not gonna lie.
I really did.
I felt like I was...
I felt like I personally was 1v3ing this.
I will say.
You...
Not gonna lie Yeah Two kills Fast turkey would have won the
133 With a hemlock Two I will say Definitely Were I was like
I thought like I was gonna get help But like it didn't seem
like it It really didn't I
Oh, turkey ghost done that.
You know what?
All right.
That's it.
I'm bringing it out.
It's time.
All right, I'm pulling out my power level.
It's happening.
Bring it out.
We're going back in time.
We're going to prime doki era.
Let's go.
I'm going super saiyan.
Why is everyone playing Catalyst?
Is Catalyst that strong, chat?
Is Catalyst that strong?
She's...
To the time where I wasn't washed.
This is it.
I think, oh my god, 22 players in queue.
The queue is so long, though.
Her queues are huge.
Is it really?
Alright, we'll try Fuse and Cadillus.
I feel like Fuse is a good solo character.
If we can't get Fuse.
Their fucking reinforce is always pretty good.
What the fuck?
Okay, um, that...
Ooh, that tracking, though.
That tracking.
That tracking was a little...
Ooh, to be desired.
Alright.
New and old.
God damn, everybody wants to play Fuse.
I guess Octane?
But he's too fast.
He's too fucking fast.
Alright, we'll try Catalyst.
We'll try Catalyst here.
I would love to play Octane, but he's so fucking fast.
I feel like I'm just...
I'm going to get...
get I'm gonna get frazzled I'm gonna get like what's the
word I'm gonna get overwhelmed with how fast he goes you
need all the help you can get the pants are holding you back
I was thinking of the super chat thank you thank you I you
know what I wasn't even wearing pants in the first place the
pants have been off since the beginning what all right here
we go
oh my god they all of them like equip cosmetics and
everything that's right time traveling back it's 2000 and
it's 2020 it's 2020 and we ain't we're not here to we're not
here to play we're here to game
and team over there I heard the bow check is really strong,
is it?
I heard it's strong, but I don't know if it actually is.
Oh my god, people are calming.
Oh, I want to take the hat, the...
I want to take the carbine, but there's no fucking...
Wow, looks like the next ring drew thin.
There's no, like, light ammo.
I would have taken the carbine.
Take the bat.
window pushing on your left is he I hear him oh that's fine
didn't have to do anything let's go you just walked in the
open like a noob I haven't used a bow check in a long time
so that I don't know this ain't gonna be pretty it's not
gonna be I'm really not gonna lie.
I hear you.
At least my Q and look at the size.
I do want a different gun.
I'm not... I'm not a fan of my loadout right now.
I need an R9.
What do you say?
Oh, here?
I'll bring my gun up.
On your left left.
he's here okay there you go world's most apex assassin he
had no weapon
oh that's sad that's actually sad he had no wait i'm gonna
keep this in case i find our night
don't worry i got you
oh my god he had wait i hit him I mean, of course I knew
him.
I'm gonna say it in.
Don't worry.
My guy, what?
Okay, that's five.
Faster activation.
Spikes are hidden?
Wait, that's strong.
Okay, that's five.
Oh my God, he fucking.
There you go.
Fucking easy.
Where's the last guy?
What's
that fucking move?
Okay.
that movement was sick though i have to say that was some
sick ass movement
you had sick movement but it's too bad you died i'll grab
this
yeah i know that movement was sick though you know you tried
yeah can't move when you're fucking you get punched oh grab
the alternator for now actually i want the i do want an r9
but i can't seem to find r9 right now i'll grab the
alternator for now i heard pk is really strong too yeah
movement can't save you from my god from my fist wait i
don't want oh that's okay i'll go head over oh i was too
early have this squad to remain all right have my mag
um there are teams behind us don't have a lot of ammo which
makes me a little oh never mind oh makes me still makes me a
little scared
nor do i have a oh okay
maybe oh come on
Where's your team, little guy?
Wait, I hear him.
What the fuck is...
What the fuck?
Are you real?
I can't say that because the last time...
Like, I don't know.
Remember the last time I asked people if they were real and
apparently they were real players?
And then I feel bad.
Love a team, I think.
is ultimate the thing is i can't never tell anymore i can't
the last time i asked if someone was real they were actually
real players
oh my god i didn't realize fuck that was my bad i got a
little too cocky there
i'm okay
I'm okay
We're survivors There you go get in here Boom I leave
There you go All
right Jesus Christ My shields need a bit more power I'm
gonna check.
I don't have any more grenades.
He's getting shot by...
Oh, fuck.
Oh, no.
That's bad.
That's bad for us.
What the fuck?
Okay.
My shields need a bit more power.
Please keep a shield, please.
I thirsted him.
He's running.
There we go.
That's fucking right!
Oh my god, I got an R9, too.
I get rewarded.
I played C.
so patient there and i get rewarded for it that's fucking
right that's right see look at that i can be paid i told you
it's the it's the new skin suit i swapped skin suits i'm
back i'm back baby i'm back and i'm killed in it oh these
ladies come down i do this every day like it's hot like it's
hard come on guys what the fuck is this gun holy shit wow oh
my god it's doing wheelies oh my god oh my god it's a drone
It's doing actual wheelies on my hand.
I've never seen that before in my life.
What the fuck is that?
I'm doing tricks and everything.
It's like my little skate deck.
It does feel like really thick, though.
I don't know if I'm like fat or that.
Where?
Oh my god.
I was like, where was that?
I knew where the fuck I'm getting shot at.
It'll be really... Oh, I see it.
I don't have any nades, though.
What the fuck?
I don't like that.
The reload.
The reload is too much.
That's crazy.
I did that much damage with my R9.
Reloaded throws me off What?
Did you just hear that?
Oh, yeah, thank you for the raid!
I'm sorry, I didn't see who raided me.
But thank you so much.
Could like...
I want to push through that, but I don't know.
I got you, Vector.
Wait, really?
Whoa, oh my god!
There we go.
That's fine.
Where are we?
Rotating.
wait a minute where are we rotating guys oh shit oh shit no
I was breaking out oh my god I covered them I covered them
for this too I fucking covered these guys I I covered these
guys in the back line just to die like that never trust your
teammates play for yourself always I wish I could just die.
Always play for yourself!
Oh my god.
I literally covered my team by killing the team, by killing
the people that were flanking us.
No, it's no use.
If I crawl, I don't want them to get my loot.
I'm trying to make sure they don't take my shit.
I want to, yeah, they should give a give up so they can
craft me and press me.
never play for the team because I wanted to take the
redeploy and then my team was getting shot in the back so I
covered them and then they left me to die they left the ace
they didn't even try and craft me oh my god can't even get
rest they better oh my god bro I died for that
I truly died for that.
Oh shit, I crafted the wrong thing.
You crafted the wrong thing!
Oh my god, I died for this.
Recharging my shields.
I died for this.
Oh my god!
I died for this team!
If I was there, we could have won.
We could have won if I was.
was there.
I died for their sins.
Was not worth it.
It truly was not worth it.
You could have won.
I died for these whiffs.
Never again.
Never fucking again.
And you have the audacity to put on the print badge.
The free...
By the way, all the badges are unlocked.
So, like...
All the badges are unlocked.
So, like, you can put anything you want, technically.
So, like, I could technically...
Alright, let's see.
I could technically put, like, all bronze badges.
Just for fun.
I can do that right now.
And what's this?
Oh.
What the fuck?
That's new.
Okay, I'm...
stuck here excuse me let me excuse me always loading stolen
valier exactly stolen valier
i gotta wait though i have to wait my everything is loading
right now
this is the only time you can use it never again
Never again.
Alright.
Oh, it's World Edge.
It literally swapped the World's Edge.
Here we go.
Come on.
Let me change my skin.
I want my badges.
I gotta go back to the first screen.
How do I go back?
Like here?
Does this fix it?
No?
Oh, do I go to...
Return the main menu.
Maybe.
I'll return the main menu At least like the map Nope No
Alright fuck it We'll just queue up
That's fine That's fine We'll just wait
It's okay I can wait
Please It's okay Come on Hurry up Let me in Let me in Let me
in It's an early access version, so, you know, things can
get a little buggy.
But it is an early access version.
But tomorrow, tomorrow, is when the full version comes out,
chat.
Last team was so bad that the game fucked up.
Okay, but, but, but I pulled, I was technically, I would say
I did so much for my team there.
I could have used my I don't know There was like barely
moments to use your alt I feel like if my team was more
coordinated I could do stuff with my alt But this is not
This is solo queue So what am I expecting?
The fact that I haven't played first person in a long time
too Um Um It's It's been a while Since I played first person
Alright World's Edge.
Then I still got it.
I still got it.
I was stuck in third person for so long.
It's like riding a bicycle.
I still got it, guys.
Oh shit.
No.
I- No!
I was trying.
They move on.
I- I pressed escape.
No, I wanted to play Fuse.
I'm sorry, they're both old.
I got lost.
Oh, hey.
Oh, my God.
Of course I'm the top ranked.
I did so much there.
They were both old.
I got lost.
Oh, yeah.
Master of the jump, right?
They're both so old.
I couldn't tell which one was which.
I still got it.
Lost it, loses it instantly.
Still got it.
I don't even remember how to play Ballistic.
Oh shit, am I fighting people?
No, okay.
Oh my god, this...
Oh no, capital city.
all right
yeah does that hit him it does that works i mean that works
for me well i'll grab the peacekeeper where
are they we're already inside the next ring literally
traveled so far professionals out of you yes i see them
they're like in here are we fighting that all right
going up
oh what
oh my god oh my god I couldn't there's too many things going
on oh my god I almost got I got what it's last guy it's
literally last guy please it's literally last guy oh my god
there's no way he loses that this is a 1v1 oh he's rising
too Come on.
I have to do this.
That's fine.
He's raising all everybody too.
Good lord.
I might make professionals out of you yet.
Oh my fuck!
That's my bad.
I didn't realize all three of them were there.
That's crazy.
Holy fuck.
That's my bad.
was in there oh i thought i could get i was like okay the
resin is actually two and then it was all the entire army
that's my bet i shouldn't have like you ran in there wrong
house wrong house guys wrong house i was also the wrong old
man literally the whole team i thought i was like They won't
expect me Like In my head I was like They weren't gonna
expect me Coming in so printed In the end I It was me It was
me that I I didn't I didn't expect them in the end My whole
The whole squad pulled up Oh man I want to change my stuff
But it won't let me cover.
Hope you hear more of your singing future.
PSU took my first donation.
Oh, thank you.
Carl, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm really surprised how well the cover has done.
I legitimately thought that I was really scared.
I thought I was going to flop because I recorded a song when
I was like really, when I was like sick.
So I was just like coughing a lot and everything.
So I was really scared that I wasn't going to, you know,
that like it wasn't going to be really good and people would
be like, oh, she sounds terrible but thank god i'm so happy
i'm so happy that everybody liked it um but yeah i thought
it was the i thought it was the best song too for the
anniversary and the new outfit reveal because like i felt
like my outfit was very you know my outfit is very
alternative punk rock-esque and like avril lavin is like the
punk princess at that time at back then and i've always
loved avril lavin's song and she's also canadian it's
literally a canadian national anthem if you think about it
national anthem please stand up but yeah um so um i'm really
happy that um everyone uh enjoyed uh enjoyed the cover and i
did so well i knew i know i knew people were stacking early
access fucking of coursey i was just checking out the
streams like people were streaming uh streaming Knew it.
I'm always the solo queue experience.
Hey, hey, you, you.
I'm your girlfriend, but no, no, no.
You need a new one.
Classic.
It's alright.
It's okay.
I don't need, I don't need a stack.
I don't need no stack.
I am practically three people.
I'm practically three players That's right I don't need
anyone to hold my hand I can hold my own hand
I'm the solo cute princess
Yeah One old man versus the world
That's right I can carry myself I
I don't need no maidens.
I am the knight.
I am the white knight.
Yeah, now this time.
Now we just need the correct old man.
That's all.
We just need the correct old man.
And then everything will be fine.
Chad, we just need the correct one.
it's okay this time
oh my god guys come on come on give me the lobby give me the
lobby not old enough look they both have the same beard they
all blur together i see beard and i was like oh that's the
right one right
they had the same facial hair it could happen to anyone.
And it happened to me.
It's okay.
We got this, guys.
This is it.
I believe this is it.
It's time.
Come on.
Give me that game.
We have the players.
It was like 100 plus 150.
Team players in queue.
We got the players.
Where is the lobby?
Where is...
Oh my god.
Also, thank you everybody for, um, grabbing, uh, the mini
dokees, the travel size dokees, um, at the dokee merch
store.
It exceeded.
I was very surprised how many we've sold in, in just two
days.
Um, we've, we've like, basically, like, you know my my
manager my distributor we're scared that uh we weren't gonna
uh we weren't gonna sell like uh enough like we're gonna not
gonna sell enough for the amount that we have to get to
lower the uh lower the price oh my god we gotta get the
right where's the wait where did he go wait they took him
out no wait where did he go where did he go wait where did
he go
Did he retire?
Where did he go?
He vanished.
Why does he disappear when I want to play him?
I don't understand.
He's like, my shift is over.
He fucking clocked out.
They disabled him and gone.
I didn't even have time to...
I had no plan B.
i had no plan b he went back to retire he's retired i was
like wait a minute when the world needed him the most he
vanished he went for his nap at siesta time holy i hear a
fighting above me right now i'm scared oh shit you can have
that oh you can have that house i'll be here whoa oh my god
wait how did he sneak in upstairs and he lives my entire
team is upstairs oh my god why can't this guy be on my team
what why don't i get the on my team.
Oh, it's done.
Oh, my God.
I don't...
The crazy part is that my team was in this building and then
they let this Bangalore just stay down there.
Oh, my God.
Wait, do I...
Should I reboot?
I'm going to reboot the game.
I don't like that.
I want to change my badges.
I'm going to reboot my game, guys.
Now for another five minutes.
I assumed that my team cleared the bottom floor Because they
were all chilling in the second floor Like They were all
hanging out on the second floor But silly me assuming my
team covered the first floor
You assumed it wrong I did not expect a person down there
Your first mistake was assuming.
The thing is, his entire team was dead, so he dragged me
down with him.
It's like, if I'm gonna die, I'm gonna make sure I dragged
us.
No!
I can't, I still can't.
They took my money now.
I don't even know you see this.
It's minus 9999.
Oh my god.
Now they've taken my money, too.
Now I've been dead in Apex.
wrong now I'm she's in debt now let's go that's crazy that's
actually crazy what if I like crash at wig's party hey wig
he's by himself but he's in game and then Let's see.
Toki, please.
Is he playing against real people?
He is, right?
Is he playing bot lobby or with actual people?
I can't tell.
I'll leave the party.
Oh, yeah.
As I was saying, thank you, everybody, for pre-ordering the
anniversary merch, guys.
You guys exceeded my distributor and manager's expectations
because they got really, really worried about especially the
plushies too because we have to order a lot to it so that I
can make it $25.
So thank you everybody for ordering.
I really, really appreciate it, guys.
Thank you, guys.
We won't be like...
We won't have...
What's the word?
Like the overstock, like the dog shirts.
We won't be drowning in dog shirts.
Okay, we are still drowning in dog shirts, but like it won't
be like the dog shirts, guys.
We're actually selling them.
we're actually we're actually able to move the merch but
this is also why dad we revoke dad lost his privileges for
more more dad merch now due to uh due to low numbers
unfortunately uh dad will be will be suspended for new merch
ideas Where did he go?
Where did he go?
Where did this go?
He's just gone.
Wait, actually.
What happened to him?
What time?
Wait, a dad lost his privilege.
they just showed there just wasn't enough what's the word
there just wasn't enough um what's that word
he was just died the man yeah there was wasn't enough demand
guys they took him to the shadow realm can you feel the
speed I can't believe it.
I selected one wrong...
The wrong old man.
One tab.
And then he fucking got...
He got fired.
I don't know.
He retired or some shit.
He quit his job.
God, he has to grow thicker skin.
If that's all it takes.
Oh my god, nice.
First blood.
And not the good blood moon kind.
Yeah.
Oh my god, I swear to God, there's no, do not make me
fucking queue another luck.
Oh, that's close.
I'm gonna...
There you go.
Yeah!
Get beamed!
You guys like that beam?
Oh, that's hot.
Still got it.
There you go.
What the fuck?
I'm trying to...
I'm covering?
Oh my god, I tried to cover.
All right.
I mean, there's another guy.
What the fuck I can't fucking ping it.
I said you legend, thank you.
Oh my god, I almost got it.
What the fuck?
Jesus.
I'm trying.
Bro, bro, chill.
There's two people there.
Yeah, I need you to chill right now.
Now I can cover.
I don't have enough ammo
Oh my god I'm out of ammo Is it worth it though Okay Okay
that was crazy
Stupid Fucking idiot Give me your shit.
Fucking
course, that's a new team.
Oh, fucking course.
You can raise that thing.
I don't think he can.
I'll let you know.
She's pushing right now.
You're crazy.
I'm fucking dead.
That was a brave race.
Oh, my God.
I fucking knew it.
I was like.
Is that a goddamn routine?
Is that...
Just like old times.
Just like...
I thought it was like one guy.
I heard one pair of footsteps.
So I was like, that's fine.
I can take him.
And then I got fucking firing squad.
I...
I got fucking...
Like, got gang banged there by two people.
I was like...
God damn it.
No, is it?
I thought- I think Wigg is playing an actual bot lobby right
now.
Why is he playing a fucking full bot lobby?
I'll message him.
Wait, when this- okay, it ends in like an hour and a half.
Yeah, he's literally it.
Why is he playing a full bot lobby?
Yo, you wanna- You wanna play together for the Axis?
Alas.
All right.
I think, you know, it is a nice, it's like a breath of fresh
air, because I haven't played in a long time.
So, like, for me, all of this is like, all this is new to
me, you know, like all the new mechanics, all the new perks
and everything.
And it's like, it's fun.
It's fun re-experiencing with breath of fresh air after,
like, not playing for a while, like, after taking a little
break.
You know?
It's nice.
I still can't believe they vote they keep they he just quit
I can't believe it he just actually just quit so I just got
in the game and I almost embarrassed myself almost like my
flight to him but then I shot myself wait with who I
couldn't tell who it was my choosing thoughts would have won
and I would have done it I'm like, we're like retired.
He was like, I've done my time.
She got a skin.
Watson, I think.
Lobbies are bugging people.
The thing is, I don't know how rank is going to go.
What the hell?
Doki bird?
She got a W.
Wait.
Oh.
She got a, she got Watson skin.
Whoa.
And they're like, wait.
That's the, that's her.
Water solid now
That's a girl with the Watson skin I like how they just
stopped talking right up I wanted to go Oh my god I'm a
little scared So you're like I don't know where Luke is on
this map This is bad.
I actually don't know where loot is on this map.
I didn't get anything.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I actually have no loot.
I have no gun.
Okay, whatever.
Well, I have a bow check now.
Oh my god, that's someone's reading.
Oh my god, please!
Is there any gun?
Other than the Bocheck!
That lifelike just ran in front of me.
What?
Oh my god, please!
Oh my god, damn.
I just want like an actual gun gun.
Would be nice.
Where are they?
Oh my god, that guy.
Oh my god, wait.
There you go.
Yeah, they're here.
That's fine.
I'm sure you're seeing this guy.
I don't care.
I'm covering.
Alright, nice.
I don't know why he, like, ran through that thinking Like, I
don't know.
He's like, nah, it's fine.
He's not gonna see me.
And I'm like, God, I'm like, bro, I can still, like, see you
through the smoke.
You're not, like, take...
Okay, I like that, actually.
I'm gonna get this out of here, though, before I do
anything.
Oh, my God.
There's a window that's just there?
Like...
I don't know if I like that.
Get him.
I told you it's too fast!
It's just too fast!
I told you!
It's too fast!
I'm not... I'm not okay.
I'm not okay with how fast this is.
Fire.
Oh,
that's not ours.
Where is he?
Oh my god, how did he know?
Oh my god.
Bye.
I got one, guys.
I know I didn't have a...
I'm sorry!
The catalyst and the altar look the same to me!
The characters, they all blurred.
together it's been so long guys you have to admit it's been
so long that all the characters tend to blur in
he's not gonna shoot my feet right oh he is fucking idiot oh
you guys stupid as hell for pushing me there but then that
means i can't i can't rise i'm gonna try and rise again what
the what all right i'm gonna try again cover me Oh, I'm
going this way then.
There you go.
Okay.
That's unlucky.
Oh, I can't, I should not have been wasting my ammo for
that.
This is so unfortunate.
Um, I do not have ammo for this, but...
Do you want to just like...
Let's leave.
Goodbye.
We'll craft them.
Are you fucking...
There's another squad.
Must go.
There we go.
There's actually so many squad.
I win.
I see.
It's bad they're just gonna chase me.
They're just gonna chase me.
How?
What?
Oh my god, at least I grabbed some light ammo.
My fucking...
Oh no.
This bitch is in here.
I can just craft it.
I have enough meals.
Wait, is that crafter?
That is, alright.
I don't have enough meds.
I'll just craft them.
I should be allowed.
I should be able to craft in zone, right?
You didn't change that, right?
Alright, there we go.
Weeeee!
It's fine.
I made it.
Wee!
See, easy.
Oh.
Wait, I didn't realize she was still...
Oh, that's awkward.
That's awkward.
I didn't realize she was...
It's fine.
I couldn't save her.
Wait, I didn't even thirst her?
Nice.
There we go.
I'm a hero Yeah, no octane movement is crazy in this game,
but like he's so fast.
He's so fucking fast I'm like getting He's really fast like
he fucks with me so much Watch I'm an actual hero.
She crawled so far Oh, I hear a fight in front of me my
naked ass R9 too, by the way Holy Get that solo he's over
here Where?
Oh, there is a solo.
Well, I have no...
Oh, my God.
It's fine.
This is all close range time.
Wait, what?
What is this?
Okay.
Alright, let's see if he's still here.
I'm gonna get shit on in a 1v1.
We'll find out.
I like pushing limits as much as the next guy.
But we gotta go.
No?
I heard a play.
Oh my god, my first attachment.
My actual first attachment in this game.
Oh, here?
Alright, let's go.
I'll grab this too.
That contained.
Someone got it.
And then there's the dormant thing too.
Where does your...
What does your eagle eyes tell you, Bloodhound?
Oh, hey.
Animals don't really have anything.
I'm betting a lot on close range right now, honestly.
I've been my entire life on this close range shit.
At least I didn't die to the ring.
You know?
Ooh.
It's on the other side, though.
Of these walls.
No, that's our altar.
Our altar has a passive where he can...
Here.
They're like here.
I don't want to use my Q in.
Because, like, I don't know where they are.
I'm too scared to, like, just run in.
Oh.
I don't get, like, a little surprise.
Okay, they definitely heard that, though.
Oh.
I'm pretty sure they heard that I swear I'm too fast I'm too
fast I told you I can't I'm too fucking fast
I'm too fucking fast I hate it it fucks with me so much
I'm sorry I don't need it I'm too goddamn fast oh my bro you
gotta stop letting that happen to you bro my naked fucking
r9 I hate it I can take that Yeah.
Okay, maybe not.
Really here?
I'm just getting chitted out like, what the hell?
What did I do to them?
Why is the ult here?
I mean, I got, I broke him.
Yeah, he has to come over though.
Oh my god, this is bad.
I had the backup.
He has to come over.
Alright.
Where are they?
They have to come.
Okay, we gotta go to the right then.
Well, I'm gonna grab that car, actually.
I'm gonna grab that car.
Please!
I don't even know.
Magazine can be swapped between...
What?
Is that what it is?
All right, I don't know what the fuck I got
This is actually really stupid or smart Bottom
He's inside Surprise
wait he's okay surprise me I guess okay whatever surprise me
wait yeah I was like guys there is a res in front of me a
res yeah
oh my god sir okay okay he's not.
Oh, let's try this again!
I'm so fast.
I'm way too fast.
I can't get close.
Let's grab two.
Let's try it.
Let's grab two cars.
Maybe it'll be better.
Two cars, infinite ammo.
Let's go.
I do not fuck with that not gonna lie I actually do not fuck
with that speed not here
car one and car two
bottom I think yep where
That's two.
Wait, I'm in the open.
I'm in the open.
I don't know.
Oh my god, he's fighting in the OP.
He's fucking crazy.
Oh!
He's gotta stop doing that, I will say.
He should really stop doing that.
Not very smart.
You ran in the open!
What do you mean?
Oh my god, you ran in the open.
My mouse is tweaked out.
Bro.
I couldn't do anything there.
This guy.
But my mouse is tweaked up, bro.
Like, he runs straight in the open air.
No, they got both my cars.
Oh, no, they got both of them.
Don't you don't understand?
It was his mouse.
Oh, I gave them two cars.
Right.
He doesn't get...
And he gets rest.
And I died.
Never again.
Never.
Never help him.
Bro, died like 10 times.
Like, bro, there's something wrong with my mouse, guys.
Never be a hero.
Yeah, his wrist timer was so low.
Okay, guys, I will say I'm not a fan of Octane.
Because, like, I'm not used to...
I'm not used to the speed.
I really am not.
I was just like, I was like, oh no.
How do I aim?
Oh no, what do I do?
I enjoyed the movement.
I will say the movement felt amazing.
It did feel amazing.
Amazing the play when I'm running around but then the moment
I bring out the gun it was I was not it I think like if I
was on controller I think I think like it would be it would
be like better if I was on controller with the move with the
speed because then I didn't have to focus on the aim the aim
assist will do it all for me but uh but then I had to
control my own aim for that
i love i love the bee hopping no bee hopping was very fun
with octane
it was very fun i felt like i could like dodge a lot of
injects drugs i'm too fast it's too fast
all right let's get octane i know octane no octane no octane
oh no i need to store your character that would have been my
I'm gonna I'll go bloodhound I want to try bloodhound no way
you know I changed one octane for you what the fuck is oh
that's right that's right that's right that's right I don't
know I feel bad because I needed to octane and this is the
way you treat me that's right let him feel bad no it's not I
know they sound the same but I remember that baited me.
I want to...
Wait, am I the first EN VTuber to get something for the
anniversary?
I don't know.
I know JPS got a lot of...
JP got a lot of VTubers that got into the Apex for Apex
anniversary, but I don't know if I'm like the first EN.
Oh my god.
That truly is such an honor.
waiting as well but you've actually had it worse I'm so
sorry oh my god that's crazy that I'm the first ENV tuber in
the game all right oh my god we'll get you back don't I oh
my god you're so PMA I'm not used to it I'm not used to it
he's so fucking positive in in apex legends I will quick
scope him in the nuts that oh crap I've got a long bone I
got some get I'm very honored for opportunity.
Oh my god.
Oh crap, this is another vibe.
This is another vibe.
I don't see anyone.
Hold up.
Oh, I hear an orange.
Oh, you scanned me.
It's not good.
Don't die me.
Birdman.
DB.
Oh my god!
Oh crap.
I saw her, someone break a window.
okay oh my god you're the best you save my life all right i
didn't rise there was a try jump i forgot about that i
really forgot about the try jump oh good scan how's it going
jesus i don't like know if i like that i
don't know if i like the try jump in general that's a new
bloodhound right or did he rest isn't I knocked up
bloodhound oh I need something I need I need like a gun
that's not on those that beak here I swear oh my gosh okay I
need bring this window there you go I guess fucking crazy
what are you doing
There you go.
I'm him.
Well, I hope he lives.
Alright, nice.
There's no team.
Oh, that guy just got absolutely railed.
I swear to God.
Alright.
I'm him.
Okay, what do I get?
Oh, it has to be this.
I need the loot.
That's right.
Trying to happen.
a ttv name he got destroyed buddy oh my god your viewers are
watching you getting destroyed it's embarrassing i oh we're
out what the fuck no i'm dead oh i'm definitely dead oh no
No, wait, that's three!
That's three!
That's another team!
There's no way they rest them in one second!
There's no way!
They rest them in one second!
Like...
I was like, oh, there's just two guys.
And then I fucking...
I fucking rolled like a fucking limousine rolled up.
And he went, bop, bop!
They did a fucking drive by.
Scan said five people.
You know, it could have been three clones.
You know.
Your viewers just watched you die.
Like he said.
Yeah, but I didn't have a TTV name.
That's different, chat.
There was no TTV name.
It could have been three clones.
You don't know that.
The scan could have lied to me.
saw three clones.
I wasn't sure.
I thought I saw three clones.
It could have happened to anybody.
That's true.
Alright, we'll try Bloodhound again.
I wish I...
Oh man, sometimes if I was a controller player, our team
would be the dream.
Honestly.
He would have been...
in the dream just let my aim assist take the wheel and i
just run at them
i'm just not used to how fast his move it's just so fast i
get lost in the sauce i truly do i whip up my gun and then
it's like we're in my aiming eyes
no i don't like responsibility
Get ready.
Moving out.
Oh, shit.
I like how people, like, wear all the, like, cosmetics and
stuff.
At the moment, they, uh, they put all the cosmetics on.
I'm gonna grab this Eva 8 over here.
I feel like if this was Ring, then watch it would be really
good, but it's not Ring.
Somebody's here.
Alright.
On our side.
On our side?
Yeah, he is.
Where's his teammate, though?
I'll grab the Mastiff, actually.
Oh, never mind.
I guess I won't grab the Mastiff.
Very nice, very nice, very nice.
Look at that.
I contribute it.
I shot the down guy so I can buff up my damage stats.
There are people fighting here.
I want to fight that team, honestly.
I'm scanning it.
Wait, what?
Oh.
I'm going to scan this.
I swear to God, I heard, like, gunshot sounds in there.
Unless, I think my range didn't.
Oh, nice.
What?
Oh, shit.
There is people here.
There is people in this house too, but whatever.
It would be nice to...
Wait.
Oh my god!
Oh, it's Dre.
It's Dre.
Okay.
It's a guy that's been playing every day.
He's been playing every day.
Makes sense.
You're crazy for that.
You are fucking crazy for that.
Oh, he's over here.
You know...
It's a guy that's been playing Apex every day for seven
years.
You know...
It's understandable.
He never stopped.
He never...
This man is three stacking!
You don't need a three stack, bro!
I'm just jealous he has friends I'm just jealous it's just
my jealousy talking it's just what fair
it's fine it's okay it's okay it's alright he's just he's
just re-stacking I'm just jealous that's right we all saw
that Trey!
This free stack won't stop you from gravity!
Imagine having friends.
Your free stack can't stop gravity.
No, Wigg said he can't play.
He's like, I had to go.
This time.
Having friends in Apex is basically cheating.
I have friends.
They just aren't in the early access.
Okay, I swear I have friends It's like I swear to God.
Oh girlfriend.
She just lives in Canada like I swear I have friends.
They're just internet is really bad in Alaska guys.
It's just really bad So just and they don't have they don't
have like the early access.
It's not like
I'm just the only one with early access, guys.
I'm the jump master.
They go to a different school.
You wouldn't know them.
They just go to a different school.
Hmm.
Doki.
Oh, fuck.
Slam my head against the wall.
Didn't wear my special helmet.
Alright, they're just in the other house.
Yay, I got the best loot in all except...
Oh, that's...
Oh, okay, there you go.
I got a gun.
Yeah, they're homeschooled.
That's why you've never seen them before.
Where is he getting shot by?
I don't feel safe anymore.
okay i could have killed him the first two shots were no
regs i fucking sucked that guy should have been dead if i
didn't get no reg in the first two shots oh my god i don't
want like being in the open here
hello guys fucking course
oh my god i'm dead oh fuck i'm dead They're gonna push me,
aren't they?
They're gonna push me.
Unless...
Movement didn't save your ass!
That's right!
Worth it!
Fucking try to movement shit!
That's fucking right!
That's embarrassing for you!
I had By the way, by the way, I don't know if you guys saw
that.
She was full HP.
I had no shields.
And I had no shield.
And she tried to fucking do a...
She tried to do a fucking wall jump tap stream.
Like, oh, she's not gonna hit that.
Like, that's okay, great.
Oh, and I'll take you out back to the...
Your team's gonna go to the lobby.
too that's a key right that's right try moving from my
fucking fist get one clip and then get fisted that's right
take them out of the lobby that's right imagine trying to do
a movement tech just to get shit on like that got no clip
here i got my clip at least a lot of these are i hope it's
getting faster it says that starting server would be awkward
if you queue together guys i forgot like oh my gosh i
remember in the i didn't realize that early access people
because like in the older early access access when i used to
do when i did the other early access in the past um it was
like you can't stack because it was all like solo queue but
now everyone is taking advantage of the fact because like
obviously obviously you're gonna run down lobbies when
you're in a stack you know like obviously like it's just
it's just easier use three stacks for easier games i
don't know i don't want to play i'll play someone else
bloodhound yeah if i have if like if i like if i have
teammates that i can rely on i'll fucking run down everyone
yeah don't know the thrill you're right the thrill of
playing with two random people the risk of it all you know
are they are they real people or like are they actual real
people or are they where they they just came out of the womb
yeah it's a test of will.
I'm stronger than those stackers.
I'm stronger.
I was molded into solo queue.
Whether they're real or NPCs.
I'm just built different.
It's not cope, guys.
It's not cope.
You see, if I was stacking, it would be so boring.
Just running down every team.
guys it would have been so boring because then the games
would be just too easy guys there's no challenge there's no
actual challenge yeah and i like the challenge
that's right
all right come on yeah i was like come on i still can't
believe they took fuse out like like what happened like what
was going on
it's early access so only like invited content creators are
allowed to play on it yeah i'm not here to get carried i am
the carry i don't fucking know i don't I'll try Horizon
again.
I'll try something with more movement.
No, they did.
They took him out back.
He literally lasted like 30 minutes.
And then he's like, chips over.
They do this to fuse.
Introducing your champion.
be clocked up for the day job done job done
all right
oh my god that fucked with me so much i hated that i
actually hated that
Oh, what the fuck?
Haha!
Oh!
Jesus.
OP fucking covers me, right?
Oh no.
Will he pink?
Nice.
Holy fuck, okay.
Alright, I'm fucking gonna medkit.
Where's the guy?
There you go.
Oh, please don't tell me you took the R9.
Please don't tell...
I'm sad.
Oh, wait, no.
That was the R9.
That was the R9 box.
Okay, never mind.
I'm no longer sad.
Sadness gone.
Oh, there is another.
I think I'm gonna change it to the sadness cancelled no
longer sad okay oh I'm this way maybe I can flank from here
I break this window
that guy's crazy I
can't I can't not the Eva 8 Okay, Eva 8 is not my gun.
It's not my gun.
The whiffs.
Oh my god.
I am an R9 girl.
What happened?
I just, I don't know.
I don't know.
I don't.
That's not.
Alright, guys.
I will say.
I'll never carry an Eva 8 again.
I'll never.
Look, we saw me hit every shot on R9.
R9.
You can't say that.
You can't.
I hid everything on the R9.
The E of 8 on the other hand.
We just don't talk about that.
We don't talk.
She was an R9 girl.
He was an E8 boy.
Can I make it any more obvious?
I'm going to have to rethink about meaning.
Okay, look.
Look.
It's, look, this game, I'll prove you guys right.
It's just, the Eva ate, okay?
The, it's because it wasn't a PK.
If it was a PK, that'd be a different story, guys.
If it was, if it was a PK, it would have been a different
story, okay?
It would be, it was just, you know, just Eva ate things.
I say, Hasako.
It's just Eva ate things.
You should have seen me with a PK.
Yeah, I'll prove you guys wrong.
Right here.
I'll pick up a PK and then I'll hit every shot.
I'll prove you guys wrong.
Right here in this game.
Yeah, my mouth tweaked out a little bit too.
It was a little bit of ping.
I was pinged too.
It was...
Guys, guys.
guys guys guys my monitor was off my monitor then the frame
dropped oh my god yes see that got to 60 frames too that was
insane it was just everything happened during that one fight
that i couldn't control that i just i don't know why i just
couldn't control anything that happened there
don't you hate it when you get pinged it okay he had a real
okay there's three people on me please shoot him and he gets
an r god i get a p20 and a nemesis look look i have a good
excuse i literally had an r like a p20 what do you want from
me That is not a solo gun.
Now that I'm an alternator, it's different.
Okay.
I walked down the wrong alley.
Exactly.
It's different now.
I got the guns I need.
I also don't think I should play Horizon.
I'm not really feeling Horizon for this.
Where are they?
I legit not feeling Horizon though.
Are you serious?
That's around the corner.
I actually got like shot bullet curve.
Oh shit.
I don't know, man.
There's a wall there.
Bro, that guy fucking curved the bullet.
Like what am I supposed to do?
He curved the bullet.
Okay, after this game, it'll be different.
After this game.
Bro, curved the bullet.
What can I do?
Okay, after this game Which monitor was turned off?
I'm kind of new and would like to know Mr. Fluggins, thank
you, Mr. Chat, thank you, thank you No, we all saw the
bullet curve chat I was literally on the right side
Is he scared?
Why is he not raising his buddy?
Okay, this right here.
Right here.
The moment they get me, I'm going to go like ultra instinct
mode.
Right here.
And the moment I get an R9, I just need an R9.
I need, okay, first off, I need an R9 and I need a PK.
And then everything will be different.
Look at that!
This guy!
Look at him!
P20!
He fucking went...
He only hit one shot on the P20, guys.
Come on.
He hit one shot on the P20.
At least I hit more than one shot.
Come on.
If anything, at least I wasn't like that.
Hatching myself up.
Okay, it's fine.
You should really swap the P20.
He doesn't even have...
Does he even have hammerpoint?
Or does he need to...
Oh my god.
Did he just get that for free?
It is.
Oh, he dead.
That Bangler's dead.
What the fuck?
He doesn't get punished for that why am i bro okay guys we
you can't judge me when we saw that come on guys there
that's better that's there bro is a book don't be cool bro
that killy kill guy does not care all right okay i think
there's a third party though i can play one day right oh you
could have stuck in oh is rave yeah rave queue was faster
for a for a while no i think they're i don't know honestly i
don't know they're sort of stuck here like this guy they're
coming over to the other side now you guys can i also play
the game i don't know why is the like oh no he fucking dead
no he's that's crazy
okay i will say that is oh he fucked that i will say that is
impressive okay i will give them that you should thirst that
though that is impressive okay now he's got i just got five
this guy plays race this guy play race it's almost like i'm
playing race
do you think he'll jump at the right time
oh what the that is such a fast that is such a fast way how
was that red so fast wait she got it off so fast did you
guys see that please let me oh my god i've been i've been
stuck in i'm they they put me in apex debt
they put me in apex debt i've been stuck here i can't change
anything i don't change that character in hero select which
is the worst part
it felt really fast yeah electro district here we come oh my
god he hit the shots when it finally met i don't know which
one i don't know i don't like how fast octane is i love his
movement horizon i feel like in the fight like you i feel
like i think maybe i'll do calis i'll play calis oh my god
ever since i swapped skin suit i can't access anything in
the game i can't access anything i keep it tried restarting
the game too a lot uh
but thank you thank you can you help me find them oh get a
ring camera that'll help you did you guys see did you guys
see the fucking oh other than the fact that super bowl ads
were all like a we're mostly ai but the but the the new
super bowl ad from the ring camera where they were like yeah
our ring cameras can control all the ring cameras that
everyone owns so if like if you lose a dog don't worry our
ring camera will find your dog we will activate it and scan
everywhere to try and find your dog and and then like
everyone's like wait a minute they can just turn on a ring
camera like that like yeah help us find yeah sure dogs yeah
that's not reassuring and he has face recognition too
obviously they all do
It's a good thing I don't have a ring camera.
I live in an apartment.
I don't know what to play.
I'll try.
I'll try Catalyst again.
I think Catalyst.
Catalyst was like the most successful.
Alright, here we go.
Nope.
Alright, I'm locking in.
For real this time.
I'm no longer fucking around, guys.
Don't worry, I'm not fucking around this time.
I'm so locked in for real.
I need to like not challenge people too much because I don't
know their controller or not.
Locking in.
I just stopped thinking I can out- I can out aim a roller
player.
Oh fuck, okay.
It's okay I didn't need a gun.
Okay.
It's so weird.
I think the energy gun is so weird.
so weird.
I don't know if I'm a fan of it.
I don't think so.
You know, I don't think I'm...
Actually, I'm not a fan of the energy.
Really, it feels way too weird.
Yeah, as soon as we get that R9 and PK, it's over.
That's where it hurts.
He's so...
Looks like the next ring
Oh my god, he's actually won!
Oh my god, I will kill you.
There you go.
Wait, this guy's not real.
I don't think this guy was real.
Oh my god, there it is!
There it is!
Guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, it's here.
It's here.
It's actually here.
We don't actually we don't even need Actually faster
activation Spikes are hidden.
Alright It's actually here I don't know That's the thing.
Last time I thought People were bots and then I Asked like a
I got one of the really bad players In my game On my team
and then like I asked Him if he's real or not like are you A
real person and then he responded It was like, I'm so sorry.
I thought you were like an actual bot.
So like, I can't tell anymore.
I can't tell if they're real or not.
I can't make assumptions anymore.
I actually can't.
I literally called like a fucking dev a bot.
Oh, man.
We have a care package on the way.
Okay.
You're never...
This was like years ago.
This was like two or three years ago.
Because when early access was not streamable, it was just
like...
You get a sneak peek, but you can only record it.
I think they finished their fight.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
That's fine.
There we go.
Alright, that's fine.
fine.
It was worth it.
Okay, I didn't think that.
I don't think we needed that.
But, like, other than that, it was worth it.
See?
I didn't think we needed the second ult, but, like, the
first ult was fine.
My ult was fine.
Ooh, I'm scared.
Watch this.
Okay, I still got it, guys.
I,
I still got it.
Oh, shit.
For some reason, I thought that was our fucking...
Oh, no.
I need that armor swap.
For real.
What the fuck?
They're on my thing.
Yeah.
Oh, I can follow that.
It's unlucky.
Oh, he's fucking crazy for that.
His teammates are here, too.
Oh, my God.
He body-blocked me.
Fuck.
No!
He got the knock on my teammate.
Oh, it's a third team.
Oh, my God.
It was two teams.
Look, I did my job.
I did my job, though.
I did everything that I could do.
Yeah, that's not on me.
That's not on me.
I played that perfectly.
Oh, then we had that Lifeline.
Lifeline.
I don't know why Lifeline fucking ran in there.
I got, she was crazy for that.
She was actually crazy for doing that.
Yeah, I was like, your lifeline, bro.
What the fuck are you doing?
Like, there was an entire team on the far right.
You crazy.
Entry frag lifeline.
I don't think that was it.
I don't think entry frag lifeline was the key to success.
I think if she, like, had...
her up it would have been fine too she just didn't have her
up she literally wasted uh with the res like she was so
paranoid hello oh my god this was the this was the person
that did her fancy movement tech and i just punched her
he's like movement and then can move away from my fist
move this
My game is so free I don't have push to talk on this game
Because I never talked around I never acknowledged randoms I
like I actually unbinded my push to talk
I unbinded it Where you guys want to go Your honor You moved
into my fist They're not real to me Yeah, who needs to talk
when I can ping?
Exactly.
I don't know where my team is going though We nice to land
together Top I'll land here
Just in case Okay, I need a better gun I'm missing every
single shot Oh, no Oh no.
I'm still trying to, I'm sorry, I'm still trying to find a
better gun.
It's not it.
Alright, oh my gosh, I'm just fine.
Oh my god.
Fuck.
I'm gonna have to drop down here.
I almost killed the other guy though.
I hear him.
me all right i'm coming over oh this is it
i'm trying to see where they are
i would like a different long-range gun though i'm gonna go
high ground
Oh Holy fuck how many people are here?
No How many people are around us?
What do you mean?
No, you're too Oh
my god, I hate this No, what the fuck?
The oh my god Why I got okay.
That that the oh my gosh, of course he's controlling the zip
line was so low Wait, I was so slow Was he on heavy that
must be a heavy gun my zip line was so slow there Oh my god,
there's another team two He's just like me.
He's just like me.
He's just like
it's just like me i told you it's not me it's the eva 8 i
fucking told you i told you it's
it's the eva 8 it ain't me it was not me bro this guy he was
he had all the shots like that again of the even eight it
was over it's not me it's the gun it's literally the gun
it's just like me
not my fault yes it's i'm clean it's the gun it really is
the gun not the player i don't like this trust the player
not the gun we neither they're here oh no but she's like in
her fucking horror game like she's like in her own like your
game right now this guy is just fucking to like trying his
head ass off right now i've seen enough buff eva eight see
he's just like me he's swapped to the vk it's just like me
like me he stopped he stopped in a pk after ladies i pray
they're just ai here please
i told you that's how i was like guys it's because i needed
a pk guys i need him and she also swapped up you also went
back to the pk
Someone fucking crashed me, man.
Get me back in here.
I had a fucking shitty-ass rampage.
And the other guy had an R9.
Like, fuck me.
I'm not blaming the gun.
But the eBay sucks.
It's not blaming if it's true.
it's not it's not blaming it but it's true if what i'm
saying is the truth oh my god just what i needed i shouldn't
need that i shouldn't need the r01 so badly there's a oh let
me grab that real quick contact
yeah I'm gonna go I'm gonna go over now I see I picked up
the wrong gun in here I think on the second floor I picked
up the wrong gun I got shit on so bad I'm scared of my one
is down here she's
come on Mario I'm not gonna risk you I just risk all my
shield for this Oh
My idea There you go, see I told you it's not me it's the
gun
I told you it's not me it's the gun
Look at that look at that exhibit a exhibit a Nice I told
you I wasn't coping I knew I wasn't coping.
I knew it I knew it wasn't go
What is this?
Okay, faster ability cooldowns.
I should need that
She was right coped into reality
Oh wait, that's how I want it want to do this jesus christ i
was not expecting that guy over here
can i go from here oh my god
what oh my god please tell me go dokey
Wow.
What was I supposed to do?
I told you it wasn't.
Look at that.
I was in the fight the least amount of time, and I had the
most damage.
I was in there.
Yeah, I got sandwiched.
All right, there's nothing I could do.
I didn't betray it.
I got pinched.
I almost killed that Bloodhound, too.
I almost killed it.
Between a rock and a hard place.
Look at this.
Told you it wasn't me, it was the guns.
Got my two guns and then I was...
I was fucking...
Classic Apex.
Ducky...
Smoking a cigarette gift.
See, I wasn't working.
washed.
It was the gun all along.
I knew it.
There we go.
No, the fuse is gone.
He like, he literally checked in for 30 minutes and then
never came back.
I don't know what the fuck happened to that man.
Maybe even got chance to try him out.
Alright.
scary i want i'll land on here just for guarantee gun yeah
no one's landing here i'm gonna get the guarantee gun first
just in case all right
already is there it in there bro my god do i come help this
old man this grandpeppy are you okay Mr. Grandpa?
Jesus.
What the?
How the?
Okay, that tracking is insane.
That was insane tracking right there.
I was not expecting, like, instant God.
I was not expecting my HP to just disappear.
Like, actually, disappear!
That guy's fire, man.
Oh my god, he crawled that far?
How did he crawl that far?
Almost ran into that.
I hear someone on my left.
He's still up there?
Holy shit, what the fuck?
Were you still doing up there?
Oh my, I don't have any shields.
like ran out by everybody let's hope this guy shoots where
the fuck did he knock him oh my god he crawled all the way
here yeah grab the alternate oh my gosh it's zero bullets i
have to run with this
what the fuck is going on
there we go oh i'm fucked up
Where are they?
I am so confused.
God, okay, that's fine.
He's one.
He's solo.
He is solo.
Yay!
Oh my god, where am I?
Like, actually, what fucking hell am I in?
Welcome to capital city.
Oh, wait, they're Rezi.
Like, what is this?
Look at the fucking capital city.
I never have a chance to res.
Oh, he's doing it again.
Is he actually on lem res?
He's going to do it.
Oh, he fucked up.
Oh.
I never had a chance to get an actual gun.
That makes me so...
Oh, my God.
We have five minutes before they close the server.
We have...
Hey!
Blaze it.
I swear to God every time Like I look at someone My HP was
just God Like this was Everybody here was so sweaty They
never stopped after seven years They never stopped I don't
know It felt like that I looked at someone And then my
entire HP was just God
Of course they win the fight After we cleaned everybody up.
Bro, my team cleaned everyone up.
And then, like, they don't have to fucking go through hell.
They didn't have to go through absolute hell.
Yeah, the old Matt, the guy, the fuse was really good.
Oh my god, wait.
Not even my skin?
How dare you?
How dare you you pick Watson it's not even my skin in front
of me in front of me that's fucked that's so fucked
in front of the dokey bird all right let's go
No.
Oh.
Well, Edge, my favorite.
Bro, I don't want to go back to Fragment.
We're always like, every time we go to Fragment, we're
always like the last, like the second last team to die in
Fragment.
We like fight for our lives and then we're the second last
team and then the last team comes in and cleans up.
I have no HP.
I have no more heals.
Oh my god, okay, that's alright.
I mean at least I get an art.
Oh my god, not the double P20.
Anything else, any other decent gun.
Ah, I'll take the prowler over it.
Take the prowler.
That's unlucky.
I'll take the prowler.
I hate these players.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, I hate these players.
That's what I mean.
Those are the...
They know how...
They know how to do the movement.
This guy never stopped.
They never...
They never stopped.
no that's like for those who like figured it out i haven't
figured it out no those are literally the people who have
like octane montages they've been doing the sun's octane
first game out
he's lucky i had the p20 if i had an actual pure tracking
gun
his tick tock clips okay guys he needs it he needs to tick i
i should have punched him he knew he was not in punching
range he knew if you can immediately obtain a facet as soon
as i saw it i was like whatever just like i was just like
i've accepted my fate i knew what kind of player he is
What kind of player this man is?
I would get, I could not win.
I, I knew how it was going to happen.
I'm the jump master.
Why me?
Have faith in off descent.
Prepare for battle.
Alright.
Last.
of near me where why oh my god charge rifle and a p20 okay
at least i got that okay i was gonna say the charge rifle
and a p20 all right like fuck me like like who am i supposed
to kill that good
I need to grab that one, none.
The perfect setup.
I got up on it.
Oh, never mind.
Oh, I still got up on it in time.
But yeah, I'm so...
Alright.
I'm gonna run Watson for the next one.
Next one is like a...
It's like wild cards.
I don't know what wild cards it is for early access.
But we'll run...
We'll run Watson for the next game.
Because I think they said that the pubs closed at 530.
I'm going to be able to hit it.
Yay!
I'm really happy to get a skin.
I feel like the reason why I chose the skin, too, is because
I felt like for banners, no one really looks at the banners,
you know?
No one really looks at it.
anything um it's just for uh because like especially you're
like you got master pred then you just put on the master
pred banner because it's just more more prestige so i felt
like and then like and then obviously it was like oh my god
what the what oh my god no i don't think they're there's
just no way yeah these guys there's no way these guys are
not real for sure
Yeah, no.
That, their bots.
No, their bots.
They're bots.
Those are 100% bots.
For sure.
Well, the Watson skin, you don't have to pay for it.
It's free.
You just have to do challenges for it.
You have to earn challenge points.
So it's just more so of grinding to get the skin.
Unless that was a baby.
real but yeah like i thought like uh banners like i feel
like no one really would use this banners in general or like
no one really looks at banners in general especially like
when you're and and they only last for like you know one
second you know from the character select like from the
character select um and then like other than that i would
have liked a gun skin my second choice so my first choice
was character skin second and also stat trackers too yeah It
is limited.
It's 7th year anniversary, so you have a limited time to get
it.
Actually, I don't remember.
Is it limited?
I don't remember.
I remember I got like some anniversary skins after it came
out.
There's that way.
Do you want to fight that team?
Or that team?
Which team?
Yeah, so I'm happy.
Because I want it to be usable for people who don't know me
and people who know me.
ends yeah so it only is a little bit of grinding to get it
but you know i feel like it's worth it oh my god they have
windows now for this you can't just nade into it
now you have to be good at apex to get the challenge points
oh i can ult this where is this plan um i can't i'm not
entry fragging this if that's what he's thinking i can't
entry frag this guys i'm literally the support what there's
an evil harvester here okay that guy is not real
he ulted for no reason
Okay, I think I can recognize the bot names.
I think it's because it's an early access, so they have to
fill it up with bots.
I feel like...
I think...
I don't know which is better.
Increase Ultimate Lifetime.
I feel like...
Doors.
Alright.
It's not a full bot lobby.
I think it's half-half.
Half bots, half real players.
They have to, though, because it's like...
Or like, you gotta wait for a very...
I thought those aren't real players, right?
Okay.
No, they're real.
They're real, they ulted.
I know they're real because they ulted.
Let's go out at the same time.
My ult goes down first though.
Another squad?
Fuck, I'm stuck here.
That's unlucky.
That team, that's a real team.
Oh!
I almost killed him too.
But I saw my team back out, so I didn't want to risk it.
Yeah, see.
Oh my god, we're getting...
Where's the other...
Oh my god, N!
Please!
Drop the portal!
Oh my god.
Okay, okay, he's got a cover.
He's got a cover.
I put a...
I put a thing there, so we should be fine.
I'll put two too just to be sure At least he dropped the
portal that's all I needed
Oh my god that's a full team too Bro that guy is fucking
crazy for going
Oh he knows
now Oh my god that went so far fast yo they all shot at me
they actually all shot at me too no
they all went for me so my hp got deleted yeah so fast oh my
god in their controller in their controller oh my god just
the life just the life of an MMK player is it oh wait is it
just the life I didn't have any nades I looked as unranked
gone now I can't tell oh my god I have access I'm no longer
dead cast oh my god I'm no longer in debt.
I can finally customize.
It's like all I wanted.
We're still rookie badge.
Oh, it's only bronze.
Alright, don't worry.
Wait.
Wait, I can't even wait a minute.
That's not fair.
I have no rights.
What do you mean?
Do I not have rights?
have rights.
They put me in debt and I can't even put on badges.
And no, everyone else gets to put on cool badges.
What do I want?
What pose do I want?
What do you think looks best?
You can see it the best.
All right, in motion.
Yeah, there we go.
We'll have that.
Oh, yeah, that shows everything.
Okay.
I can't believe it that's so fucked up oh I can't even equip
it it won't even let me equip it that's insane all right I
think wait what is the wild card anyway what is it get back
with respawn upgrade your weapon by collecting evil oh wait
that's interesting I can't believe it I can't even equip it
it might ban it i have no rights i just i'm not in debt but
they revoked everything else from me
rights denied it's because i'm cute wait let's see maybe
maybe you're right
no i just i'm not allowed i'm gonna pee real i'm gonna pee
guys
Solid.
Bye.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Also, I forgot to get water, too.
I'll be right back again.
I'm back.
I'm pretty sure this is a time where it's... Let me read.
Wild card starts at 5.30.
Okay.
5.30.
Servers close at 7.
Alright.
As long as we're... Oh my gosh.
I've been playing for four hours.
It does not feel like four hours.
I'm back, baby.
I told you we'd be back in the basement, guys.
It's like we never left.
the basement always calls for you
he always calls for you can never escape
that's me wait yokey back on apex wait who's that that's
right it's my skin it's my skin
That's me!
Just kidding.
You didn't even notice that!
That's my skin!
It's literally me!
I'm the giant monster!
Trust me.
I know the ring best.
Alright.
It's literally me.
Back in Apex.
Of course I'm back!
I'm it's literally me Okay Do you see we got some people
here All right, here we go Yeah, oh, all right.
Let's let's ship.
Oh, let's go.
That's embarrassing Oh my god, there was a There was a pk
here in our moment.
Oh down below No
Right now.
There we go.
Oh my god, how the fuck am I supposed to do this?
Okay, there you go.
I needed that.
That's right!
You're welcome!
Watch this!
Oh shit, it's not connecting.
What the fuck?
Okay, that's unfortunate.
That was not supposed to happen.
That's not supposed to happen.
I'll just say that.
Where the fuck is...
What is going on?
I'm so confused.
That's right here.
It's a bloodhound.
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna kill cell real quick.
Where am I getting shot at right now?
Because I don't know if I like this.
I am so confused.
Is that everybody?
Wait, what's this?
There's a cell for us now too.
What the fuck is going on?
Okay.
No.
I'm coming.
They're right here.
All right.
Oh my god, the res is so fast.
Wait a minute.
Holy shit, wait, the res is fast.
What's going on?
Where's the guy fucked up?
I didn't get no- I'm going backwards.
Where's out here?
Here's the thing.
Where did he go?
Oh, there he is.
Yeah, get over here, bitch.
What the fuck is...
Another bloodhound?
How many are there?
Yeah, you're good.
You're gonna watch me angle.
Come here.
Oh, no.
Oh my god, they can respawn!
That's why!
That makes so much more sense oh my god please he is so low
he is so low i wanted the iron knight so badly
no infinite blood out i was just like did i not just kill
this guy three seconds ago i swear to god i just killed this
man like when does it stop
I was like, I was so sure I killed him.
I swear to God, the bloodhounds never stop.
That's why I was like so confused.
I was like, I swear I killed you.
I, there we go.
I swear to God when killing these guys so many times.
Where is the R9?
One of them had it R9!
No, we're low, we're low, we're low.
Where is it?
I'm coming to you guys.
Zone isn't too far.
I see one landing in too.
I can't.
I'm so lost.
Oh!
Oh no.
What the fuck?
Guy!
They're all just landing in stops!
It never I just want a different gun!
I just want a different gun!
That's really all I want.
I'm dying.
Oh, it's funny.
Same team.
We've been fighting this team for 20 years.
I swear to God I We've been fighting this one team.
I'm a little bit further.
I'm gonna have me pull back a little bit.
I'm so tired.
Okay.
Get out of here, bitch.
Oh, bitch.
Bloodhounds go here.
He's down below.
Oh my god, this is it.
It's over!
He's looking over.
This team is finally gone.
It's finally gone.
He's not.
He's finally gone.
Yeah, I'm also going to get some of this here.
I feel like the smoke thing is so annoying.
one we didn't fucking hell we fought the same team fucking
oh my god i swear to god we fought the same team for so long
i didn't
he's dead he's finally dead i love how my dog is just
playing with her toys and now she's passed down free at last
i swear i killed that bloodhound like at least I knocked him
down at least five times I was like he's back I didn't
realize because like I realized about the wrist thing so I
was just like he's back again how is he still here how is he
still here how is he still here how is there way to how many
teams are in this round oh oh my
Oh my god, it's okay.
She can live.
That was so fast.
I didn't even realize he was...
To be fair, I didn't realize he was there.
I fucked up there.
What the fuck?
I didn't...
How many teams are in this game?
I didn't even... I literally got up and I was like...
Oh shit, there's a guy here.
I was not aware of this.
there was 10 there was 10 teams there was 10 teams and i
fought that one area i fought that one team like 20 times
okay there were three teams why so the other team had like
the fucking casual time of his life there's no fucking way
there's no way so you're telling me well i'm Me and the
other team were fighting for our fucking lives.
The third team was just chilling.
Okay, okay, 10 teams.
Okay, thank God.
That sounds a lot better.
I thought there was, I swear to God, if there was like three
teams, like I swear to fucking God.
I swear to God, I swear to God, it like never stopped.
same bloodhound five times okay this is like actually
non-stop fighting it never ends the fight never ends it's i
was it has fun to like non-stop fighting but it's still like
it's still like i don't know it's like on and off i have
like a love relationship over it i have a love hate
relationship right now
it's just a lot you know it's just a lot
oh my god i fucked up
holy what the that's a oh my god that's a different guy
Okay, I'm back, though.
I'm back.
Wait, where's my other team?
Are you serious?
My other teammate flew there?
Okay, okay.
I thought that's why I was like, this felt like a 1v3.
Because it was a 1v3.
That's why it felt like a 1v3.
Yeah, good luck, buddy.
My other teammate is not even there yet.
My other teammate is still not there yet.
It's like here.
I would like it if they...
Wait, do I regen?
I do.
Is it just us?
It's the same thing.
It's just us too.
I'm trying to...
I'm gonna get closer.
There you go.
He's back.
They're back.
Oh my god, they're back.
I would love an R9 right now.
I hate the car so much.
I'm just not good with the car.
What the fuck?
Y'all's gonna see.
You're new.
Oh my god, you're new.
I have
a pathfinder.
I was like wait a minute I don't remember no path oh my god
no this is bad
No he's one actually one I'm so sad I didn't realize there
was someone up there I would not have landed there if I knew
oh my god I didn't realize because he had the fucking
advantage because I had to land.
He had to fucking...
I had to land and pull up my goddamn gun!
Also, I need an R9.
I hate the car so much.
I'm so used to aiming with R9 that fucks with my recoil
control.
Honestly...
God, damn it!
Oh, my God.
I thought that was a down guy for some reason.
Okay, they're...
They're two fighting.
They're fighting.
As long as I stay alive
That's fine.
Oh My god, what the fuck is going on?
I'm just trying to live long enough for my team to respawn
Holy shit I got beam so fast must be nice must be nice Do I
have a beam gun Must be so nice
Must be so nice Holy shit that's a new team Oh my god
they're coming
That's not fair Oh team at me Wait where's my other teammate
What Where's my other teammate Where did they go?
I swear I saw two more teammates.
Wait, my second teammate already died?
Jesus Christ.
I didn't realize I was going to get rushed there.
Guys, I don't think Watson is the play for this game mode.
I really...
I really want to make...
Watson work, but she has no mobility.
She has no...
I don't know what to do.
But you gotta win with your...
That's true.
I could do it.
It's alright.
This is it.
No, I could do it.
I don't need mobility.
It feels would have been so helpful.
If he comes out of retirement, If only he'll come out of
retirement.
If only...
Do you see the old man?
I don't.
I believe in the skin.
Believe in the skin that believes in me.
See, I could have picked an octane skin.
Or maybe, like, you know...
Or maybe like a catalyst skin.
But Watson was what got me there in the first place.
She was loyal to me on day one.
I always remembered those that were there for me.
Or even Bangalore.
And she cute too.
She's cute.
Symbolism matters.
Exactly.
And she's a cutie.
Oh my god, okay.
I would really like a different gun.
I saw an R9 one time and it never happened again.
The one time I saw an R9.
The one that got away, chat.
Truly the one that got away.
We're not wrapping the EVA.
The one that got away.
I always hit my shots on the R.
Now, what are you talking about?
Oh, yeah.
You know what?
Let's try it.
You thought I could whiff?
I'll show you how.
I'll show you whiffing.
my god how did
i'll show you what whiffing truly is
don't worry don't worry eventually what the fuck how was he
behind me this this entire time this entire I literally-
this guy landed on me!
This entire time!
He just was just behind me.
That's crazy.
That's five.
See that?
I hit a shot.
There we go.
Yeah, I got my own- I got my own shit.
What the fuck?
What happened to that guy?
Oh my god, it doesn't stop.
I'm so scared.
There's someone above me.
I can hear him.
I literally can hear him.
I literally can hear this guy right above me right now.
He's still...
like he's still there he's still there we can't do anything
about it oh my god he's coming down
yeah it was worth it right staying high ground fucking idiot
oh no i bet it was so worth it stay on high ground the
entire time idiot are you fucking okay he's not real he's
not real she can't hurt me oh
my god please
how is she still okay i'll grab that just so i can grab the
up oh my god is our guy gonna be okay oh he is he made it he
made it see i told it's not warning shots anymore i'm
serious now
I'm serious now.
It's right here.
Bro, good.
Oh my god, I live for us.
One, zero.
There we go.
All right, all right.
See, that's all it takes.
I'm going to go from this tunnel.
Okay, this is a little awkward now because I have no heals.
What the fuck do I...
Can I make it?
Okay, okay.
Don't worry.
I will stay alive for us.
Okay.
The moment she lives, I'll come out of hiding.
Give me a sec.
I'll come out of hiding soon
Maybe not Why was he here?
Why were you here?
What the fuck?
No
I did Ow, is he still trying to kill me?
How?
I had two people, two people running at us.
Okay, I live.
It's okay.
I literally had two people run, like 20 people running at
me.
I got my R9.
I told you guys, the moment I get my R9, it's over.
I told you guys.
When I get that gun, it's fucking over for them.
It's all I needed.
I took...
Yeah, I took three!
I didn't even take two!
I'm coming back, guys.
Hello.
Oh my god, please.
Oh, shit!
It didn't make me...
Please.
Jesus Christ!
I played out of my mind there!
I don't deserve to die!
I literally played out of my mind!
I told you I hit those.
I told you.
Oh my god, I would have loved that blue one.
I'm committed now.
hell oh
my god i really oh my god where are they
he's right here oh my god never mind that's a mirage
oh my god he's jumping away oh shit hey i remember that guy
What?
I got you.
Oh, what?
What is he doing?
Oh my god, stop!
We have to get the zone!
We're not even in zone!
where is zone no that's not zone that oh my god we're not
even in zone
we're not even in zone that's the worst part
oh my god i'm just putting this here bro you're crazy oh my
god he shot my fucking thing
run where
run run like where
it's okay they are not gonna there's no way they look down
here there's no way there's no way they look down there wait
can I
how do I get to them How do I...
Guys?
How do I...
Maybe...
Is there a...
Can I go from here?
You think I can...
Ah!
They actually left me.
They left me into the pit.
Oh my god.
Oh, I fucked up.
Wait, I fucked up.
I didn't realize the time.
Oh, no.
Oh, my god.
I didn't see the time.
Okay.
Oh, this is so bad.
I am right behind them.
Stop it!
I was literally trapped!
Can you see me?
Oh my god, they do.
They do see me.
Fuck!
I was stuck down there!
I literally lit for them and then they left me in the hole
these guys
like what do I do there was a team in front of me and you
cannot say I choked you cannot say I choked I did so much
you cannot say that I literally clutched that multiple times
and then they let me to die in the hole they let me to
fucking die in the hole
I thought we were a team Like
They're like live And I was like okay And then they just
left They just left I couldn't go up The other team was
there I couldn't The other team was camping that zip So I
was waiting I was waning.
If only the other team wasn't camping in that fucking area.
I clutched that so much, though.
The fact that they didn't even come back for me made me so
sad.
They didn't even come back for me.
They were like, see ya.
They didn't even look back.
They actually did that to me twice.
I survived, I survived so they could rest like two times.
Remember the other hole I was in?
The other fucking hole?
And where I dragged three people down with me?
And .
Doki, I'm so sorry for kicking you in the head earlier.
Where I would drag three people down.
And it stayed fucking left.
Dude, thank you.
That's crazy.
I had some sick plays though.
I actually carry that shit.
I carry that shit hard.
I don't even remember who this guy is.
I'm sorry.
You're like, I'm sorry I did this.
And I was like, bro, I've been queuing for so long.
I don't remember.
I've already lost track of everybody I've bumped into.
Hey.
see I told you not washed not washed just abandoned just not
washed just abandoned several times holy fuck okay so I
should get a gun are you serious what the oh my God, how
could there be three...
Oh, and that's his team?
That was his team in there.
That was his fucking team in that.
Oh, God.
Okay.
The one...
Oh, my God.
Bumped into their fucking entire team.
I don't even know where to land and get loot now.
The fact that that was their entire team there, too.
That's crazy.
Oh, my God.
It's not the nemesis.
not a huge fan of that it's over for me maybe I don't know
could be over for me we're gonna find out now
oh my god everything is so fast
where alright that's fine my god okay never mind he died we
are a team of two now like a enemy of idea He's above us.
In case he fucking drops down into my...
Really?
Oh my god.
Oh
my god.
There's too many people surrounding me in this hell.
Oh, he's one!
He just never stopped left clicking!
He just never...
Stop left-clicking!
Yeah, I hope you die from that.
Okay, I don't want to be in this town.
I don't want to be in this town anymore.
This town is fucking hell.
Or even is my team.
This town is not worth it.
Like, I'm sorry.
All right, buddy, good.
But, like, it's not worth being here.
I don't know.
Man, oh my god, round five.
I think the hardest part about this is just the amount of
third parties, you know?
It's just like they could be anywhere.
They could be right behind me right now.
like oh my like right now
oh my god
oh my god okay I knew he was gonna do it see like that's the
thing they could land right behind me that's the hardest
part about this game mode they could like land right behind
me and I can't fucking like counter it Oh my god.
It's okay.
We're still, technically we're still in it.
Ninja's everywhere.
He's right behind me, isn't he?
Yeah, but this is like beyond regular third party.
This is a...
This third party extreme.
Like, right!
here okay
it could be right behind me couldn't how is there
oh my god he's right behind me isn't it he's right behind me
isn't he
Oh my god, what he is.
He's right here.
I fucking get so I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
I was like, he's right behind me.
He's right behind.
They always just land on me.
I could hear it, too.
I literally hear the fucking landing sound.
How about 50 more?
There's like a third party the game.
It's so chaotic.
I don't know.
His way is so much.
He's right there, isn't he?
Again.
I hear him.
I fucking hear him.
I literally hear them fucking running at us.
I hear the sound of bodies flying in.
He's right.
They're right.
Oh my god, our guy is so brave.
He's fucking crazy for that.
He's fucking crazy for landing behind him.
Like, holy shit, I don't know what the plan was.
I don't know if that was it.
That's not coming towards me, right?
oh my god i don't know where it is oh my god and then
there's a zone
there's someone to my left
he's right there isn't he
all right oh
wait that guy's bot that's a bot that's a bot right there
Another bot is right here.
Another squad?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Not.
There's like a little fence there.
I think it's doing it.
I can't get it further up.
It's the best I can do.
It really is.
Which one's a real Mirage?
Is Mirage good?
Others?
Which one?
Oh my god, another squad.
We have to go soon.
bro like what do you mean another squat oh no oh two one
zero he lives for us
oh i almost killed him dude that's so hilarious i live for
you that's fine that's fine I distracted enough.
I live for the team There we go.
That's the trap.
Just live for the team.
Yeah, I almost killed them too This game mode is so dumb is
yeah
My god, oh my god, please I can't live again Don't make me
do this again
Oh no
Okay I live for my team again
I live on
Oh shit I didn't think he was gonna find me Not gonna lie I
can't believe he found me there.
Really?
How do they know exactly where I am?
It's crazy.
They knew...
They always know exactly where I'm gonna be.
30 seconds to this match gets a whole lot smaller.
Yeah, but they knew I was gonna be in that hole.
Oh, my God.
You're crazy!
No!
You just had to live!
You just had to...
Oh, wait.
Was that the...
Were we the last team?
I thought it was top two, three more.
They knew I was in the hole.
They always knew I was in the hole.
He had to wait three.
To be fair, to be fair, like they were always like running
away, too.
You know what?
I did my part.
But I'm fucking playing.
I feel like Mirage has to be it.
like i feel like in this game mode everyone just rips off
mirage i feel like i don't know what you guys think yeah i
feel like mirage is crazy for this oh my god it's doki and
unstopped hi unstopped again where is mirage hello again
okay i got it i got it just in time i was like where is he
the next game that's really funny that timing
Insanity Yeah, no this this shit is great.
I think mirage is it It's been good got a dub and I think I
used that game places Must be nice to win.
I made a few dubs in a row Must be nice.
I'm not jealous.
I'm not jealous at all I'm not jealous at all I got my
content.
That's all that matters.
Hey, nice, nice.
Wait, you can have two?
What the?
You can have same characters?
How you doing, Doki?
Oh, my God.
You can have two of the same character.
I didn't know that.
They're going to say hi.
Oh, my God.
Push the talk is unbinded.
I'm not egoing people.
I just don't have it binded.
That's different.
I'm going to land.
Yeah.
I'm too I'm too lazy to breathe by because like my push to
talk is buying into a different to like uh my mouse button
but um I do not have I mean I use that to swap weapons so I
use this to swap weapons but usually it was my push is my
go-to push to talk for any other game he just got in my
building as soon as I left yeah that's timing but I think I
need an actual gun Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah.
What the fuck is going on?
I knew it the way he moved on the skin.
Oh my god.
What the?
Oh, you are so close.
I want to see I could like, fuck with it.
Well, I thought that was my octane.
I had two octanes.
That's why I thought it was one of my octanes.
octanes i to be fair it was an easy mistake i have two
octanes in my team so i thought it was one of them yeah i
was wondering i have way too many octanes in here what the
fuck come on drop on me drop on me this one's swinging your
left oh he did drop on him he did say it that's a completely
different kid not even the one you're asking for no Then
there's a team on the bridge we are into.
Oh my god, there's so...
That's the bot.
Is that a real person?
No, there is a bot.
Hmm.
Where are they?
Oh my god, he's gonna die to a bot, isn't he?
I was gonna say, that would be pretty embarrassing.
We died to a bot.
but i'm actually needed that all right that's a bot please
don't you don't compliment me that was a bot i don't deserve
it wait those guys have to be real oh my god they were real
What the fuck?
Wait, that's my skin!
That's my skin!
Oh my god, that's my skin!
Give me, don't lick me, don't lick me.
Wait!
He's using my skin!
I can't kill him.
Bro, I can't kill this guy.
That guy's using my skin.
I can't kill him.
That's Doki burn.
I can't kill myself.
Yes, you can.
I killed the imposter.
Which was the real Doki?
But which one is it?
Which one is it?
Alright.
tell me somebody saw that which one was it no that is dope
even very
wait how did you know
no no hacker hacker nice nice nice nice how did you how did
you not know i think i got hit by the auto shit or whatever
I got hit by the auto shit.
That's fucked up.
Is someone like loot delivery me the fucking R9, please?
We need you because you're eight.
Don't worry.
I can do this.
Make them feel bad, doll.
Tell them they should have came to your customs.
They played in the tournament.
Wait, what happened?
Okay.
Who did you run into?
It's okay.
That's okay.
Everything's fine.
What happened?
That's funny.
That's really, really funny.
They won't know.
No, damn, dude.
Oh, it's Voky's dude.
Oh, this guy has killed me so many times.
There's one game he killed me like six times in a row.
Oh, the game we got a six late for you.
Oh, we lost this guy.
Aw.
There we go.
Oh, he was so low.
I almost got him.
There's this team here.
Brandon, baby.
I hear you Bro, they all know each other They're like, best
friends Which one's the real one, it's not me
There's so many people Oh my god, it's just Non-stop
fighting
That's him, that's that guy I was shooting a completely
different kid and then he just like swung around five four
three two one yeah okay i did my job i did my job i did my
job of course he's got one here the question is has dokey
played dokey dokey literature club
oh my god he was one oh it was so close I whiffed it!
No!
It's the PK, guys.
It's the PK.
He was too fast.
He was too...
Blade.
I didn't think he would run back at me.
I hate Octane so much.
He's way too fast.
He's just...
Where's the heave?
Okay.
To my defense.
It's so fast.
He's so so fast guys to my defense he's zoom me He's zoom me
he's zoom me right now Oh my god not again Dang
Oh my god does he know which one's the right one
No, they know, they know.
Yeah, incredible.
Oh my god, I made it!
I made it!
I actually made it!
Oh my god, I'm a hero!
I'm a fucking hero!
Oh my god!
And I get rewarded!
I get rewarded for my heroics!
I got rewarded.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Please tell me something.
No!
Was I here?
If I pop it, everyone's gonna fucking drop and land on me.
Okay, your turn.
Bro, I just, I felt like I was running around.
I'm like, it never stopped.
It never fucking stopped.
I did my job I did my job
They read so many times They used up all the resins What can
I do?
They used it all up
They used it all up is it all up all i could do was just run
okay let's pull some wool over some eyes i literally saved
the game so many times i was a hero i should i deserve the
purple heart i do
holy it doesn't stop that fucking it's not it doesn't stop
just keeps going he's right behind me they're always right
behind me they're always right behind me guys
holy Oh my god fucking worse.
He had the whatever gun he had it was better I had the
goddamn charge up.
I'm gonna go die so I can respawn instantly And they don't
stop coming
This is like third party.
This is like third party to the next level.
I will say this is like next level third party
What the fuck?
Why would you shoot me?
He's right there too!
Why would you aim for me?
Oh no.
I believe.
I stop believing.
Oh my god.
I believe he has an R&I.
Okay.
If you rest me, I won't.
If you rest me, I won't take the penalty.
Yeah!
Oh my god, that scared me.
The actual, I believed in the power of the R9.
I knew he had the R9.
I knew he was set for life.
I knew he could do it.
Oh my god, enemy's spawning nearby.
Oh my god, they're right behind me, aren't they?
Oh my god, they're right behind.
Oh my god, how fucking course they are!
I can't fucking...
Like I'm not allowed to breathe!
Holy fuck!
When are they not fucking there?
Breathing... Oh my god!
Are you fucking
still trying to kill me?
I swear
I'll never I'll never stop It just keep coming It just keep
coming.
Oh, that's awkward for me
Just keep coming it just keep coming it just keep coming my
body never stops Okay, okay.
Surely they stop coming.
Guys, I know it's wild, but what if they stop?
Oh, but...
I was going to say, surely they'll stop coming, right?
I'll take it.
I'll take it at the moment I peek.
I fucking peek one.
I actually peaked one time and I get fucking shot at
Couldn't even finish the thought Just keep on coming.
They just keep on coming.
They don't stop.
Oh my god.
They're landing too
My god, oh My god, where can I go?
Where can I go?
Where can I live?
Oh my god.
No!
I just...
Where can I go?
I just landed.
I literally...
They don't stop coming.
I can't even breathe for one second.
Oh, and these guys have the most wonderful time of their
lives.
but they landed here must be fucking nice must be so nice oh
my god i'm literally watching two three bots right now i'm
watching three bots these three bots are just chilling
oh my god i'm watching three bots enjoying the time of their
lives playing with the door they're like what a nice day
They're so bored they started playing with the fucking door
That's crazy I'm gonna pee I'll be right back
What the fuck was that What what am I watching What is this
What the
Beep beep boop pop Beep beep
There are bots with aim assist.
What?
That was wild to watch.
That was actually wild.
Bots really do be botting.
I need to go back to the lobby and re-queue.
Oh, no.
Alright, I'll try.
I will never fully understand them.
Oh, no, I'm, oh, no, they took away my money again.
I'm not allowed to access it again.
Oh, they took away my rights again.
It's been fun, so I feel like I do want to say, though, for
sure, this game mode, you need friends for this game mode.
You need friends for this game.
this game mode it's fucking wild like i i don't know
definitely it's it's it's a lot you have to be aware of like
of like like 80 different angles
oh i it's just everywhere it's just they're everywhere i
literally i'm like where do i go where do i fucking go
they're everywhere i i would be like i'm safe emma i must i
must be safe right now right guys i was not safe i
unfortunately unfortunately i was not safe you're never safe
to fit like one to two more games before they before they
like uh
before they shut down servers the servers will be up for
another eight minutes i just need i need one get me in
get me in come on get me in let me play
let her in Please!
Oh my god, there's only 12 players in queue.
What if, guys, what?
What if they're secretly queuing this mode?
I know they said to shut it down, but what if, guys?
Just think about the possibilities.
Oh my god, I missed the queue.
I actually...
What?
No!
Oh, no.
I missed.
How did I dodge the cue?
I...
One second.
I was gone for one second.
That's all they needed.
The one second difference.
It's okay.
I still have six more minutes, guys.
It's still possible.
Okay.
it's still possible guys six more minutes
i believe okay this is it i'm gonna be so locked in i don't
even know what were was everyone playing mirage octane i
think i've seen them and and what was it oh is he streaming
i thought he only did youtube videos mirage octane and who
was who was we're in we're fucking in Oh my god.
This is it.
I didn't see any Bangalore, to be fair.
I did not see...
Oh yeah, cat.
Yeah.
Oh my god, I could have played that.
I just see...
I just see a lot of people on...
What's her name?
The girl with shields?
Oh my god, it's been so long.
It's been so fucking long.
Mirage?
What was the girl's shield?
The shield girl's name?
I forgot.
No, no.
I don't remember.
Connoit?
I think so.
Alright.
It's never gonna stop.
If we die in four minutes, we could still queue up another
one.
Connoit?
Yeah, Connoit.
Oh my god, I hate this area so much.
Surely no one's gonna land here, right?
Fucking hell.
Someone did land here.
I might not get a gun.
Guys, I messed up.
Oh, my God.
I didn't get a gun.
Surely, like...
I didn't have a single gun.
It's okay.
I got a shield, though.
Whoa!
It's fine.
who might be in town you're right i could have just died
there and then grab another kill you're right you're so
right oh my god wait i could actually wait if i actually i
don't want to be here because i have no guns i actually have
no gun like what do i do oh my god i see the gun in front of
me oh my god the last gun
guy in front of me why did you land it because I was gonna
land here and then I was just let you know what oh my god
nobody landed here I saw I swear to God saw a guy here but
that's the only reason why I fucking did not be here all
right back to hell back
to hell
what the fuck
there you go I need I don't need your shit.
Actually, I don't.
Your shit sucks.
Your fucking shit sucks.
Back to hell!
He's gonna start.
He's gonna land behind me, isn't he?
He's gonna land behind me.
I can feel it.
Oh my god, there it is.
There, which one is... Oh my god, he figured it out!
He figured it out.
I was like, which one is it?
Which one could it be?
Which one?
Oh shit.
Oh my please just get me out of this side.
I'm leaving.
I can't.
I hate this area.
I really hate this one area.
I fucking hate this zone.
If it was anywhere else to land on.
Oh my god.
I wish I could just fucking stop and kill my other game.
There we go.
This area fucking sucks.
Fuck this area.
Actually, fuck this area.
Oh my god.
Fuck me.
oh my god and we have the zone on us too oh my god and
there's a loba somewhere who the fuck is playing loba in
this game mode oh my god and i hear people flying in it
never oh my god
Oh my god.
There's nowhere to go.
I'm flying straight to point.
Get me out of this hellhole.
Oh man, we lost one.
No, I have to do extra work.
Get me.
Ninja's everywhere.
Oh, fuck this.
Another spot.
Where?
Oh my god.
I can't get over there in time.
It doesn't matter.
I was way too far gone.
It's too late for me to queue another game too.
It's seven.
It's fucking seven.
Jesus Christ.
That's way too late.
I'm going the other way.
Fuck this.
I'm sick.
Bro, I have like the fucking worst guns for this shit too.
That's the worst.
How are they still getting bamboozled?
I threw these out 20 years ago.
Take the win.
please there has to be one r9 somewhere it has to be a
single r9 please i do not ask for much just one and r9 oh my
god enemy respawning here but where are they oh i i see it i
see their fucking flight path oh hey you know what it's good
all right here we go honestly
true oh my are you so yo nice it's not me that's fucking
right give me your shit oh my god wait a minute they have a
Kramer bro I the thing is I can't fucking run Kramer into
this I can't run Kramer into this guys like there's no
there's no such thing as like far-range fight in this
fucking game mode are you serious There's no way they know.
Okay, he's coming back.
Oh my God, please.
Oh my God!
They're still just there.
Oh my God, I leave.
You're right.
You can have that.
You can have that area.
I don't want to be there anyway
Oh my god we're pincered
Oh my god Oh shit
Oh no No He got me That's okay That's okay I'm here
Oh shit It's no longer okay It's no geez, geez, geez.
It's no longer okay.
It's no...
Wait.
Shirley didn't close at exactly 7.
I can't sell first.
There was a guy right there and the other guy was in the
lobby.
Shirley.
Shirley, I could get another Q in.
I just didn't want to be there.
I was so checked out.
I swear, we landed there like 20, like, The last four games,
we landed right there.
And I was so checked out.
I was like, I hated that place so much.
That place fucking sucked.
I hated it.
I was so close to just leaving that game.
I was so close to leaving.
yeah because i couldn't find a gun that area sucks why does
anyone land there you get barely any loot there there and
like it's just hell it's literally hell
it's actually it's actually hell on earth that one area i
was happy with i swear to god was more crazy like even skull
town was better than that area i will say because skull town
there was more distribution of players around the town but
like everyone was just congested in that one area and you
can and it was like where do we go it's a mosh pit it's
literally a mosh pit of doom at least skull yeah skull town
has more town
okay now i'm sort of okay with the re45 i made it work i
made the r the re45 work
oh my god please one more game one more game my left who
left we were at no they closed the server it's not fair
It's not fair.
They put me in hell.
I didn't want to play that lobby.
I had to fight in hell.
I was this close to leaving when they took me back there.
I was this close.
I wanted to leave.
No!
They closed the server!
Oh my god.
That's fine.
There's still... It's possible.
People just gotta believe.
We just need more people to believe.
Oh, wait, like...
Oh my god.
No, they're leaving.
Why are you all leaving?
I don't understand.
Don't leave.
Party's just about to get started, guys.
I'm in my second win.
They don't, the time they go.
Honestly, I will actually go back to regular.
I need that one win.
I felt like I got cucked so hard in my games.
Literally, like, every time I get close to winning, my
teammates leave me.
like games where i fucking carry
all right that's it i know what to do it's top wait seven
players regular would be better because like um i don't get
like uh because like it's more there's more like players of
different skill level for here it was literally like and the
fact that like all the players and the big content creators
were three stacking too but like but all the pros and the
content creators they're not gonna be playing pubs that's
the thing they're not gonna be playing pubs they're just
gonna be playing cooking rink yeah like i was like one of
the few people that wasn't three stacking or dual queued all
right it's time it's fucking time because the only people
who have access to early access are just content creators
and pro players that was i was having that's why like i was
getting like the fucking never stopped after seven years
they're stronger than me they really are because it's like
you know you know sometimes you need variety in your life
but these guys they're like inject apex into my fucking
veins and you're like injected into my veins we're never
leaving and they're stronger than me
all right it's time this time okay we're not playing watson
i don't have my skin there i don't remember what i was
playing but i was still playing or maybe this time i can oh
i can't even play fuse i don't know i feel like catalyst is
still good right bangalore
but i think i'm like bronze i haven't touched oh wait they
do placements now right oh yeah i'm all the way at the right
side I'll go Oh, I haven't unlocked I haven't locked him on
my account This account
I'll do Catalyst I think Catalyst is fucking strong Overall
I think she's pretty strong Increase maximum active spikes
Alright Let's see solo queue warrior experience.
Not me.
I literally won my last game.
While I was warming up.
Alright, here we go.
I'm the jump master.
This time.
Where are we gonna go?
Oh my gosh, this map.
I have not seen this map at all.
For the entire time in the early access.
It was out of rotation.
Why are we going?
People are already dead.
Okay, it's either he's lagging or I'm like, okay, it's him.
It's him.
It's like, oh.
It's this guy.
It's not me.
It's actually this guy.
This guy was not it.
And this guy was not having it.
Alright, let's see it.
I don't know.
Like, I'm like, I'm like a love-hate relationship right now
with this R.
I think, like, the R.E.
was really good at certain moments.
There were so many close games where, like, if my team
didn't leave me to die, or after I sacrificed myself for
them, that could have won.
There's so many.
i was like team please
i just need my r9 no i'm okay this guy was laggy as hell all
i find were like energy guns jesus that's all there is
weapon enhanced nothing a bit of elbow crease i think i can
get back into my like i i will say i'm like super rusty and
depending on what gun i'm using like pk i will say I'm super
rusty only because like there's not really guns that there's
not really like shotgun characters in like hero shooters in
general especially in support but like oh no no I feel like
if I just play this regularly I just get back into it I mean
I've been I was hitting my R9 shots I was hitting my R9
tracking shots Because that's my shit.
That's my gun.
I feel like I was holding my own.
Despite having played it for so long.
Yeah, was that?
I mean, I did whip shotgun shots, but it's only shotgun
though.
It was only shotgun.
Alright, but the last half of the game with Wingman, I hit
everything.
I hit everything during the last half of that match.
Literally clutch that fight for my team.
I can still beam.
That's right.
Oh, nice.
Increase max number.
I would go with that.
I still need that.
Oh, there you go.
There's a carbine.
I'll take that actually.
I need my R9.
Where's my R9?
Oh, holy shit, it goes all the way.
I don't remember that.
Well, nobody's here, though.
Oh, well, they know we're here now.
What the?
Oh, shit.
Stupid.
They're like right here.
I'll give them a pierce.
Oh my god, there's Sayonara, I guess.
Fuck his team.
It's Sayonara.
We'll fucking Resio later.
I guess.
That's crazy.
They literally left that poor man.
They're like, we'll craft you.
We'll remember you.
We'll craft you later.
That way?
Oh.
How long?
I still have time.
Well, I hope I can still...
Alright.
I don't think he saw me.
Oh, no.
He definitely...
One HP.
Actually, one HP.
I'm so sad.
He's...
He's solo.
Oh, my God.
That guy is so low!
He's gone.
That guy is gone, gone.
He ain't coming back.
Wait, what?
You're so dumb.
Holy shit.
He fucking moved.
If he didn't move, he'll be fine.
He literally moved.
looking idiot he literally died because he made one sound
stupid as so stupid does that take me oh no oh my fucking
god a fucking course I can
all right
oh my god no
no fuck ah the re the re fucked me up ah i did so much too
the re what oh wait one guy was not performing the re45 the
charge up it threw me off also not works.
The RE through throws me off sometime.
If I had an R9, they would be dead.
They would be so dead if I had an R9.
That's it.
I'm gonna do it.
I'll never have to reload.
It's a love-hate relationship.
Sometimes I'm like, I'm fucking killing it.
I'm fucking killing it sometimes.
Okay, they won They're using, yeah, but it's not It'll be
there tomorrow Chat It'll be there tomorrow So I better see
you guys I better see you guys wearing it Tomorrow Well, I
don't know Well, it takes a while to grind it It's time to
play the old man I'm still so sad I didn't get tried I
didn't get to fucking try out I don't understand why they
took him off Like what was broken You didn't seem that
broken
All right, and then All right, here's a rule If you see
someone with the Watson skin You It's a start We start You
start teaming That's a joke, guys That's a joke, do not
team, guys That's a joke I don't want to get in trouble
Holy shit that's an entire fucking team
Oh my god
Jesus Christ Are you fucking kidding me?
I had the shield cell here How many people are here?
Oh
my god that's another team Get over here Get over here over
here get over here and i will res you oh my right why what
is he doing what the fuck was our watson do you know our
watson could have res them but she what was that did you see
him did you see our watson also why the fuck did it even
crawl to my corner and i was like oh fuck it whatever
are Watson doing?
I don't know why he crawled that way.
I actually don't know why he crawled that way.
He could have crawled my side, but he was very insistent on
going to my right.
You know, I was just like, bro, okay, whatever.
Yeah.
And then, did you see that Watson just looked at us?
She just stared at us.
She didn't even try to shoot back.
I was so I was like, what is he shooting back?
What's he doing?
He actually just looked at me.
He just stood there AFK.
And like, that's on you.
You got this, right?
Don't you?
I'm like, I see Watson.
bottom right she's just laughing bro patria said he was
super chat like thank you i have no idea what the game plan
was for lat watson unless there was no game plan
i don't think there was a game plan guys i think the plan
was just to watch yeah he just wanted to watch i mean all
right to each their own sometimes people just want to watch
Oh my god, another...
I swear to...
Yeah, I never find an R&I when I needed it.
I never get an R&I when I needed the most.
Fuck, no.
I might need help though.
Alright, can I get through here without getting shot at?
Let's find out...
What's that?
Oh my god.
watch this let's i like risk how risk how reward famous last
words
oh no
where is my team like is he oh i mean who am i telling this
to myself i guess
Like I was like, I'm me.
I swear to God, they're all like running away from me.
Like I'm trying to engage in this fight.
Oh my, what the fuck out of me?
Okay that got beaten the shit out of me.
That was on me.
I played my mouse placement was wrong.
Holy fuck!
Who's the real character?
Who's the real Mirage?
No, my mouse placement was on the wrong one.
Whoops.
I thought I was...
For some reason, I thought I was something else.
How do I...
Boom.
Alright.
Let's see.
Increase alteration.
Double the number.
I feel like alteration, right?
It would be the best.
Yeah, I know.
I'm throwing this game.
Please!
Oh my...
Oh my god, I keep thinking I'm something else.
That was my bad.
I keep thinking I'm a different character.
Let's hope there's someone else here.
Alright, there we go.
Yeah, I keep thinking I'm smoking because I don't play it.
I don't play Ballistic that much.
So I feel like I'm doing a smoke grenade or or, like, Mirage
Q, because I was telling Mirage in that crazy-ass game mode.
I hated that game mode.
I still!
Okay, that was a sick shot.
You have to admit, that shot was sick as hell.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Where did he go?
Oh my He actually shot back.
I did not think he would shoot back, bro.
Get out of here.
Execution style.
That's right.
Get out of here.
Oh my god, he's controller.
That makes a lot of sense.
He has a teammate, though.
Like, I had to do a finisher, so...
friends wherever he is hmm where did your homie go I had to
finish him so you did have friends must be nice must be so
nice I'm not jealous at all well not jealous at all nope I'm
all right it's not like I went through solo queue hell
earlier today?
Nope.
You know what?
I'm gonna be solo queue tomorrow and tomorrow as well.
For Overwatch.
Alright.
Exactly.
Who needs friends when we got sick ass skin?
Holy shit.
This guy's far far.
Yeah, you guys don't remember?
Five characters are in shadow dropping tomorrow.
But I won't play Jetpack Cat.
I'm so looking forward to Jetpack Cat.
Of course I am.
I'm playing Launch.
Holy shit.
He's fucking crazy.
Or a little bit faster, though, at least.
Another squad?
This is not good for us.
I swear to My ult is about to end So There we go
I'm all to excel this Just because like I wasted that entire
ult for that
Oh shit Wait a minute That's another team
What the fuck
That's another team That's okay the windows aren't here yet
We're still fine.
There's no windows yet.
Holy fuck you're crazy.
There we go.
Never dealt my wingman again, chat.
We did it, guys.
Oh, there's a golden carbide.
I'll grab the EVAC.
I need...
Okay, fine.
Alright.
Where are they going?
Alright, this way.
There's still three more squads left.
Or two more squads left.
Here we go.
I saw someone over here.
dead what is he shooting at oh i see him i see the car how
do we get up i see it okay wait oh he's all the way above us
that's not good
what the what wait what the where did that guy come from
Yeah, that's right.
Come back.
Fucking crazy.
I'm always fine.
My team's got this.
Oh, my God.
Bro, he's fucking portaling away.
So scared.
Wait, why would you?
I mean, I'll take
why would you give us high ground what where is he okay
there you go why did he give us high ground like I'll take
it okay they literally gave us high ground I'm not sure what
was the plan there taking high ground world tournament
announce it
watch this
easy just just drown them out in the shield look at that
easy i told you the moment cube puppet fucking is so easy
it's let's go let's go i know i could ego these players i
couldn't i was like i knew i could ego these players oh my
god fucking easy all right there you go we did we got one
win
oh yeah forgot he has a third weapon that's my bad i forgot
that was his thing he had a third weapon there we go see i
don't need friends i could pub stop by myself i my oh yeah i
forgot that i i forgot this guy i don't play this guy at all
but i was just like Yeah, I feel like I should be more
aggressive with him.
Yeah.
See, I still got it.
I still got it.
Still have my aim.
Just takes a while.
Because I've been in third person.
I've been in third person jail for so long.
Literally.
I still got it.
Yeah.
To pub stop.
Look at that.
I can still pub stop.
I don't need friends.
I can pub stop solo queue.
I still got it.
Took me a while to get back in the first person.
But, thank you all for coming, guys.
I really, really appreciate it.
I hope you guys are excited.
I hope you guys are as excited for the skin as I am, chat.
I can't believe...
I can't believe it's real.
I can't believe it's real, guys, that...
actually in apex legends oh my god i honestly never thought
this would ever become a reality in like i thought i was
like you know past my prime past my apex prime you know
but i really appreciate that the apex devs reached out to me
and picked me to be part of the seven year anniversary event
and um being able to be part of history being the very first
to be in the game.
It really is fucking crazy to see.
And being able to have, being able to choose Watson as the
skin to represent me.
Because I have a lot of memories involved and how I got
started and how I reached top 500 before when the top 500
was just 500 people and not 750.
But thank you guys i hope tomorrow tomorrow you'd be
grinding that's for that skin and meet up all the other
dragoons wrapping the dokeybird skin and before i forget um
tomorrow we are also launching i showed this before but the
people who didn't see it tomorrow we are also launching the
official watson x dokeybird plushie yeah to celebrate the
collab to celebrate the cosmetic in game you can get your
own physical watson doki too tomorrow you can pre-order this
tomorrow i'm making a tweet about it um yeah thank you guys
patricia thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
she's back on so cute it's my time before the bangalore
takes the hold of her thank you super chat thank you thank
you so yeah wow really amazing things to celebrate um to
celebrate and enjoy uh this week is it's jam-packed we have
a lot of stuff uh we have today we have the apex stuff today
which we did tomorrow is overwatch wednesday is a sponsor
that i can't say what it is because i have to wait for them
to announce it but you guys sort of might know what it is
because it's another shooter game um thursday is state of
play watch along they said it's going to be an hour long so
we're going to do a state of play watch along on thursday um
um friday I don't know.
Friday might take a day off.
I'm tired.
Friday will be my rest day.
Saturday is dad's birthday.
And then Sunday is the PUBG tournament and also Monday.
Also, unfortunate news, Kony had to drop out because he
accidentally double scheduled for it because he already
scheduled something else on Saturday.
So I'm sorry, on Sunday.
So unfortunately, Kony had to drop out.
I have no idea who the replacement yet.
I'm still trying to find a replacement.
So I have to figure that out today.
But yeah, thank you all for coming, guys.
It's been a while since I played Apex.
I think the last time I played Apex was the last time I
streamed A... Wait, no.
The last time I played Apex was...
Wait, yeah.
The last time I played Apex was the last time I streamed
Apex, which was with and we just played that and then and
then we took a long break and now now we're back again so it
i i love i you know first person shooter it was always
really really fucking fun um because it's a different you
know it's first person versus third person it's it was
really nice to get back into it i love beaming people with
the r9 and everything i definitely am very rusty because it
has been a while since i've controlled like some of the guns
in i don't know r9 is like literally riding a bike i don't
really need to learn like relearn how to track but um the
other guns it took me a while to remember how to uh re like
to regain the muscle memory for it but i think like the
longer we went the better we get the longer we went the the
more we got back the skill uh so i hope you guys have fun
watching have fun watching me with too uh i told you guys
It's not me.
It's the Eva 8, guys.
It's not me, guys.
We all saw the other...
We all saw everyone else whiff with the Eva 8.
Those players that haven't stopped playing Apex, guys.
We all saw it.
We all saw it, guys.
Yeah, yeah.
PK, I blinked.
Okay, the PK was Octane, guys.
No, no, no, no, no.
no no i was against the octane he was too fast he was too
fast you don't understand he was so fast you don't
understand he was so fast
i'm not it's been so long since i fought someone that fast
uh
um anyway guys as always everybody say hi i'm ready to
posture check get up and around to get that blood flowing
instead for me head to bed because you deserve it thank you
again guys i couldn't have made it this far without you
dragon supporting me the fact that you know i was someone
that was important enough in the apex community to be chosen
to be part of this event um obviously like not a lot of
creators are picked for this each year so the fact that they
picked me to be part of it and as one of first and the first
env tuber um to receive something and it's caused like an
actual character skin too is insane to think about and you
guys help make it happen like without your support without
you guys cheering me on while you guys watching me play
these types of games i wouldn't have been able to uh i
wouldn't have been able to have this experience and be able
to you know be part of something like this so Thank you,
Dragoons, and I really cannot wait to see so many Dragoons
wearing this skin in the wild, um, in Apex, and just seeing
guys with the, don't keep, you know, you're, like, repping
me in general, um, whether it's rank or pubs, um, it's
really cool to think about, and, yeah, hey, guys, I'll see
you guys later, everybody, bye-bye, everyone, bye!